[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
ממש. טוב, אז בשיעור הקודם התחלנו לדבר על סיקוונס מודעות.
בגישה הדיסקרימיננטה בבית מישהו?
מישהו יכולים להזכיר לנו למה היינו מעוניינים להסתכל על גישות עסקים להטביות?
מה יהיה הקושי עם Home בהקשר שלנו?
אז בוא נלך עוד צעד אחורה. מישהו מכם יכול להזכיר לי את ההגדרה של Home של Hidden מרקוב מודל?
מודל קלאסי, פיקציה נרטיבי.
אוקיי, באיזה בעיה אנחנו עוסקים? נגיד, מה הבעיה שמלווה אותנו בפרק הזה?
כן. הייתי אומרת את זה כבר במודל של חוזה קטגוריות ואז נוצרה קטגוריית חוזה.
חוזה את זה שבעצם או מייצר את הX.
בעצם כן. נכון? אוקיי, יפה מאוד. תודה.
אז בוא ניזכר בהדגמה הקודמת. עורכי דין מארק אובמה אמר בעצם שיש לנו בעיה כזאת.
כן, יש לנו סדרה. סליחה.
אנחנו רוצים לחזות סדרה של תגיות. כן. למה אנחנו חושבים על זה כסדרה של תגיות?
בגלל שיש תלות ביניהם? אוקיי, הפרידה שלנו לאחד תשפיע.
תשפיע על הפרידה שלנו לאחרים, ולכן אנחנו מעוניינים לבצע את הפרידה הזאת באיזושהי צורה ביחד.
כן לבצע הפרדה דיקציה משותפת לכל הלייבלים האלה ביחד.
אז יש לנו איזושהי סידרה כן של לייבלים שאנחנו רוצים לחזות.
בדרך כלל במקרה שלנו בקורס הזה זה יהיה טקסט, פסקאות או מילים או משהו כזה.
כן, זה יהיה פשוט חתיכות טקסט שמופיעות אחת אחרי השנייה, ואנחנו רוצים לחזות סדרה של תגיות שיש ביניהם איזשהו קשר, שיש תלות בין גישה נאיבית.
כן לבצע את זה לא תלך. כי מה אומרת הגישה?
נאיבית. גישה נאיבית אומרת בסדר, כל אחד מהווים האלה יכול להיות שייך לאיזשהו L לאיזושהי קבוצה סופית של תגיות.
כן, נגיד, נחשוב טיפוסית כמה עשרות תגיות, אולי כמה מאות תגיות.
כן, אבל למרות שזה מספר תגיות לגמרי ניתן לניהול באופן כללי במערכת הפיקציה.
מרגע שאנחנו מדברים על לעשות שרשרת של כן שרשרת של פרדי קציעות, אנחנו נתקלים בבעיה מהי.
בשנייה אחת. אוקיי, ולכן התלות אחת בשנייה ולכן אנחנו לא פשוט, יכולים כל אחת מהם לחזות עצמאית.
נכון? ולכן איזה קושי נגרם?
פשוט נגיד, אנחנו רוצים לחזות את כולם ביחד כמקשה אחת חישובית.
אולי זה כן נכון? אז כמה רצפים יהיו לנו כאן של תגיות?
נגיד שהגודל של n זה 40 אז.
כמה תגיות, כמה רצפים באורך n על 40 תגיות.
ארבעה בחזקת. כן, בדיוק 40 בחזקת. נכון? אז יש לנו המון.
אנחנו ודאי לא רוצים לעשות את זה. לא רק שאנחנו לא רוצים לעשות את זה, כי החיפוש עשוי להיות מאוד מאוד קשה.
נכון, יש לנו מרחב בגודל אקספוננציאלי באורך הקלט.
אנחנו לא באמת רוצים לעבור עליו בצורה כזו סיבית.
זה לא יגמר אף פעם. יש לנו גם בעיה של Space, נכון?
כי הצד השני של זה זה בעיה של ספר סטטי בלמידה. מה הכוונה?
למה אני מתכוון לומר שמרחב תגיות בגודל עצום יוצר בעיה בספר City?
אוקיי, נכון, אז בעצם יש המון המון תגיות אפשריות אם על כל רצף תגיות.
אני חושב עליו כמשהו כאיזשהו פתית שלג ייחודי שאני צריך לאסוף עבורו דאטה בנפרד מאחרים.
מטבע הדברים, לא יהיה לי מספיק דאטה כדי לשערך בצורה מהימנה את הקמת התפלגות הפיצ'רים שמתאימה לרצף התגיות הזה, כי פשוט אין סיכוי שיהיה לי מספיק.
בטח לא Data מתויג ידנית, אבל גם data שלא מתויגת.
אני פשוט כמות גדולה מידי ולכן אנחנו רוצים להניח הנחות בפשטות.
נכון, וכמו שאנחנו נתקלנו בהקשר של Language Model זה מרקוביץ הנחה נחמדה שמאוד מקטינה את הסיבוכיות של הבעיה,
אבל עדיין שומרת על תלות מסויימת, גם אם יותר מוגבלת חסומה בין התגיות.
זה ההנחה. הנחה שבעצם התגיות מהוות.
אפשר להתפרץ. פר תצפית שזה דוגמה אחת לכאלה.
כן, אבל איזו הנחה סטטיסטית הנחה הסתברותית מקובלת שאותה השתמשנו בהקשר של Language.
מודלינג של שרשרת מרקוב.
אוקיי, אנחנו רוצים להניח של שרשרת מרקוב. כלומר אנחנו רוצים להניח של התפלגות וואי אחד.
אדווה en מתפרקת, נגיד שווה try גם.
אוקיי, זה יכול להיות לאיזשהו סדר. אם זה try גרם אז זה מכפלה i שווה 1.
אם כן, אנחנו מניחים בדרך כלל איזשהו y אפס ולפעמים גם y אין פלוס אחד.
כן y אפס start או stop הם כותבים מכפלה אין פלוס אחד של הסתברויות המעברים נכון why i בהינתן i מינוס אחד i מינוס שתיים אז זאת הנחת המקובלת.
ההנחה הזאת היא טובה לנו מבחינת הסיבוכיות של המודל.
נכון, גם האינטרנט נהיה פתאום יותר יעיל וגם הלמידה נהיית יותר יעילה.
בוא נתחיל בלמידה. למה למידה יותר יעילה?
כי אם קודם לכן הייתי צריך עקרונית לראות איזה פיצ'רים, כן, איזה שרשראות מתאימות,
לכל אחת מהן קומבינציות 140 בחזקת n, נגיד אפילו שאין קבוע קומבינציות אפשריות לתגליות במקרה כאן.
מה אני צריך בעצם להחזיק איזה? 3.
אז ככה בעצם אני צריך להחזיק.
אין אין בחזקת. 3. כן. אוקיי כן.
אז בעצם מה שאני צריך להחזיק כאן זה פשוט את ההסתברויות המעברים בין Y לבין כן זה לא.
אין סליחה זה s כן כאילו אין l בחזקת שלוש.
כן אין בחזקת שלוש. אני רק צריך להחזיק את הסתברויות המעברים בעצם בין זוג לזה שבא אחריו.
כלומר, אני צריך להבין את הסטטיסטיקות של שלשות.
זה דרך אחרת לנסח את זה נכון. אני צריך להבין איזה, מתי מקורות כן או מתי.
סביר שאני אחזה שלשות מסוימות. כן, להבדיל מסדרה ארוכה של תגים כן.
אז שלשות מטבע הדברים מרחב הרבה יותר מוגבל באורך שלו.
כן, אז יש לי עכשיו 40 בחזקת 3 במקום 40 בחזקת n.
בסדר יפה אז זאת הנחה מרחבית ומסתבר שהיא הנחה לא רעה הרבה פעמים תלוי בסדר למרות שהיא לא מושלמת.
נכון, דיברנו על זה שהיא לא מושלמת למען למדל תופעות בשפה על ידי שרשרת מרקוב.
זה דבר שבכל זאת מוגבל, אבל לא נכון.
צריך לקבוע את הסדר. לכן צריך לקבוע איזשהו סדר קבוע. אנחנו נתייחס לזה בהמשך השיעור היום.
איך אפשר להתגבר על זה? אנחנו צריכים לבחור סדר קבוע, כלומר איזה אי תלות מותנה אנחנו מניחים?
האם יש להיות מותנה בהינתן לקודם שניים הקודמים, שלושה הקודמים צריך איכשהו להחליט.
אבל מה עשית בשפה? יש תלויות ארוכות הרבה יותר מזה, ונתנו לזה דוגמאות.
אז אי אפשר באמת לחסום את זה, ויחד עם זאת זאת הרבה הרבה תופעות.
זאת תופעה מתקבלת על הדעת. כן, זאת הנחת המרחב. פתאום אתה צריך להתחייב לאפס.
כי בכל מקרה, קודם כל אתה כן צריך איכשהו.
אוקי, אז אפשר לנסות להתגבר על זה. הקונטקסט הוא כל כך לוקאלי, אבל אז באמת כאילו אפשר.
אפשר לנסות לעשות אקסטרה קולקציה, אבל אז באמת שאלה איך עושים את זה?
זה כאילו זה. זה מסתבך. העסק הזה בגדול, אבל ההנחה הזאת מגבילה אותנו.
מצד שני, נותנת לנו ערך גם בלמידה וגם באינפרא סנס.
מה שראינו. אלגוריתם שנקרא מי שזוכר.
הם ימים. זה היה מודל אחר. מודל סקרים מנתיבי. איך נקרא אלגוריתם שמוצא?
מהי דעת העסק ב home?
אוקיי, תכף ניזכר, בוא ניזכר קודם במודל הזה, אז גם זה נותן לנו בייסיק אפשרות לבצע תכנון דינמי, אלגוריתם שנקרא ויתר B שדיברנו עליו פעם הקודמת.
יפה עכשיו סבבה של סדרת התגיות.
אנחנו מניחים לגבי המחבר כרובית, אבל זה עדיין לא הסוף, כי המודל הזה בסך הכל אומר לנו איזה סדרות של תגיות הם סבירות יותר אפריורית ואיזו סבירות פחות.
נגיד למשל, אולי נגיד אז part speech נגיד very very very very very very.
40 פעם לא סדרת תגיות כל כך סבירה. נכון, לא נשמע מאוד סביר.
לא אומר שאי אפשר לעשות את זה כמו נגיד למשל זוז, זוז, זוז, זוז, זוז.
נניח שאפשר לחשוב על סיטואציות מוזרות, אבל כנראה מאוד נדירות.
לא, לא מאוד סביר אפריורית, אבל זה בכלל לא מקשר אותנו למילים.
ברור שאנחנו רוצים גם לקחת בחשבון את המילים של המשפט ולא רק את ה prior.
וכאן נכנס באמת ההנחה השנייה והיא שההסתברות של איקס איי בהינתן האיקסים הקודמים.
והוואי הקודמים. בהינתן כאילו הרשע והוואי שלו.
סליחה. והקטגוריה שלו היא שווה.
למה? זה?
בדיוק זה הסתברות של איקס i בהינתן Y, כלומר כל מה שהיה סטטיסטי מספיק עבורי או כן ערך מספיק עבורי כדי לדעת לחזות את x, y זה הערך של וי.
איי. לא צריך להסתכל על המשפט. הזה וזה mission population זה transmission נקרא וזה ממש נכון.
ואלה בעצם הפרמטרים של המודל. זאת הנחה מאוד מרחיקת לכת בתנאים מסוימים.
אולי נשמעת הגיונית בתנאים של שפה ככלל לא.
כן, בוודאי שיש תלות בין המילים שלא מתווך מתווך דרך, מתווכת דרך מתווכת דרך הקטגוריה.
אבל. אבל זאת ההנחה של HTML בסדר, ואמרנו שההנחה הזאת היא הנחה שבגדול היינו רוצים להיפטר ממנה כי היא מאוד מגבילה אותנו.
כן, היא הנחה מאוד רדיקלית. וחוץ מזה, למודלים גם נרטיבים יש קצת בעיות אחרות גם.
וגם על זה דיברנו ולכן. בקיצור, המסקנה המתבקשת היא שאנחנו רוצים להסתכל על מודלים נסקרים מנתיבי.
רק אולי כדי לסיים את זה נרשום איך נראה Home. בהינתן שתי ההנחות האלה?
כן. טוב, אני מקווה שאתם זוכרים מה כתוב שם. אז איך אפשר לכתוב את מדליית שמן באופן מלא?
אז בוא ניזכר. אז פי איקס אחד זה home.
ספציפית write. הייתי אומר. איקס אחד המיקסר וואי אחד.
אז וואי אם זה שווה אז זה כמובן תמיד נכון שההסתברות המשותפת לי שווה לפריון על פני עלי בנים כפול עלי כנהוג.
כלומר, ההסתברות לראות את האב, את מה שאנחנו רואים, את המשפט באותם התגיות.
זה פשוט הגדרה של הסתברות מותנה.
חובה שתקראו לזה. ועכשיו אנחנו 0.
אנחנו יכולים להניח לגבי כל אחד מהם להשתמש בהנחות נכון?
אז הגורם הראשון למה הוא שווה? כן, המכפלה של.
כן כן, בדיוק זה מה שכתוב כאן.
זה הנחת המד קוביות. היא שזה אחד אן איי איי במקום מינוס אחד 202 והגורם השני אנחנו יכולים לפרק אותו על פי כל השרשרת.
נכון? ולקבל את זה ההסתברות של X איי בהינתן איקס אחד עד איקס מינוס אחד ואז סליחה.
אה כן, X אחד וארבעים ושרשרת ה Y.
נכון, והדבר הזה שווה לפי הנחת הקוביות שזה פשוט להם יש לנו פה בבית.
אז כן. ואם אתם רק הקצה שלו.
וזו ההגדרה של המודל. קובי חבוי Home כי זה מרקוס model ואז נדבר עכשיו.
איך נראה הדיסקרימיננטה במודל? אז דיברנו בשיעור הקודם על אחד שנקרא M.
כן, זה המודל הראשון שהסתכלנו עליו שהוא בעצם מודה שגם הוא, נניח, הנחה מרקוביץ.
הפעם הנחה מרקוביץ מותנה?
כן, כלומר, בהינתן האיקסים, בהינתן המשפט מניח ששרשרת התגיות מהווה שרשרת מעקב וכל אחד מהגורמים כל אחד מ הפקטורים במכפלה הזאת הוא עצמו מודל או גלינארי.
כן, מודל לא גלינארי בהינתן הקודם. זאת אומרת כן, זה במקרה של בי גרם כמובן.
אפשר בקלות להכליל לטרייד גרם אם מוסיפים כינוי מינוס שתיים,
ובעצם אנחנו מניחים שכל אחד מ הפקטורים כאן הוא מודל לא גלינארי, כלומר הוא מתקבל כסקורר לינארי.
את פונקציית פיצ'רים קבועה מראש F ומנחה מה שנקרא מנמלים אותו באופן לוקאלי.
מה הכוונה מנמלים באופן לוקאלי? הכוונה היא שכל אחד מ הפקטורים שם מסתכם לאחד על פני כל האפשרויות שלו.
כן, אם אני סוכם פה על כל הפרטים האפשריים למילה I אני אקבל אחד.
אוקיי, כי זה הסתברות. כן, זה פשוט מתפרק. והדרך שאני גורם למודל לקיים את ההנחה הזאת, מה שנקרא נרמול לוקאלי זה זה שגורם לנרמול שלי.
כאן הוא גם גורם נרמול לוקאלי, כלומר הוא סוכם על פני כל האקספוננט של ה score על כל התגיות האפשריות לוואי i, כאשר y מינוס אחד נשאר קבוע.
כן, זה נכון.
אז למה בחרנו כזה? אז לצורך העניין הזמן חוזרים על זה ברמה הזאת או שאני אוכל להסתבך בכל מקרה אמת.
אם אני לא לוקאלי אז זה כופה עלינו את זה. למה לא ניר לנרמל לא הסכימה היא אקספוננציאלית, כלומר פשוט של כל ההסתברויות.
אז זה עכשיו? בדיוק על זה אנחנו מדברים. עכשיו זה המודל השני שנדבר עליו, שהוא כן, שלא מניח את ההנחה הזאת.
אז זה בדיוק יהיה הנושא. עכשיו, כשסיימנו את השיעור הקודם איתו ועכשיו אנחנו נדבר עליו.
אוקיי, למודל אני אומר ללוקה לי יש בכל זאת יתרונות שאני סוכם על מספר קטן של כן, הגורם נרמול הזה הוא trace table.
כן, הוא קל לחשב אותו, הוא פשוט סכימה לX מומנטים של כמספר התגיות אפשרויות.
אוקיי, אבל. ומה האלטרנטיבה? אז כדי להבין מה האלטרנטיבה ולמה שבכלל נשקול אותה, בוא ננסה קצת להבין מה זה אומר.
שהמודל הוא לאו כלי נורמלי או שהוא מהווים שרשרת מרקוב.
אוקיי, אז בוא ניזכר בטראנס כאף כן, אני אזכיר לכם.
זה פשוט דרך מאוד נוחה לחשוב על סיקוונס Models.
כן, דרך גרפית. בעצם אני אומר אני מתחיל. נגיד שמסתכל על מקרה בי גרמי.
אוקיי, פשוט כדי לא לסבך אותנו. ונגיד שיש לנו תגיות AB ו C על התגיות האפשריות שיהיה קל לשרטט.
אז בעצם סליחה.
אז אנחנו יכולים לצייר דרך. אוקיי, אני יכול לצייר גרף שכל מסלול בו או תיוג אפשרי.
כן. אז מה הכוונה? זה הוואי? אפס זה הוואי פלוס אחד.
אוקיי, ואם זה השכבה שמתאימה לבואי אחד שתיים, אולי פחות אחד וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, יפה. ועכשיו איזשהו מסלול בגרף הזה.
נגיד למשל, כאילו בעצם בגרף הזה אלה הקודקודים של הגרף.
דבר ראשון הצלעות. אז הצלעות פשוט בין כל שכבה לשכבה שבאה אחריה.
יש גרף דו צדדי מלא. בסדר. כן וכן הלאה.
נכון, יש. אוקיי, עכשיו אם אני משרטט איזשהו.
אם אני משרטט איזשהו מסלול.
אם אני משרטט איזשהו מסלול כי אני בוחר איזשהו מסלול זה, זה לא משנה, זה זה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי. בעצם אני יכול להגדיר את המשקל שלו כמכפלה את משקלי הצלעות.
אני יכול להגדיר משקל כל צלע. אוקיי.
הסתברות המעבר הזאת. אוקיי, אז נגיד, מהי ההסתברות של A בהינתן שווי אחד שווה בהינתן?
וואי אפס שווה בסדר זה האיקסים וכן הלאה.
לגבי כל אחת מהצלעות האחרות. ובעצם ברגע שאני יכפיל את משקלי הצלעות, מה שאני אקבל זה בדיוק את ההסתברות המשותפת לסדרת התגיות הזאת.
ועכשיו המטרה שלי תהיה למצוא מסלול כבד ביותר בהתאם French למצוא מסלול כבד ביותר, כלומר כזה שאם ממקסם את מכפלת מספר הצעות,
את מכפלת משקלי הצלעות ואת זה אפשר לעשות באמצעות תכנון דינמי יותר ממה שראינו בפעם שעברה.
עכשיו הנה המגבלה שיש לי. אוקיי. ברגע שאנחנו מניחים שהשרשרת הזאת היא שרשרת מרקוב,
או באופן שקול שכל אחד מהמעברים האלה כן משקלי המעברים האלה מסתכמים לאחד לוקאלית, אז הדבר הזה עשוי במקרים מסוימים להגביל אותנו.
כן, אז. אז מה זה אומר? שהם מסתכמים לוקאלית או מה? זה אומר שזה לא קלין או בלייז?
זה אומר שתמיד סכום משקלי כל הצלעות שיוצאות מכל קודקוד הוא אחד נכון, חייב להיות אחד.
אין לי פה שום משחק. עכשיו בוא נחשוב על מקרה שבו אולי הייתי רוצה שזה לא יסתכם לאחד.
אוקיי, לדוגמה? נגיד למשל אוקיי, היה לי פה איזשהו קודקוד שהוא עצמו היה לייבל מאוד נדיר נגדית.
השני. אוקיי, הוא כמעט אף פעם לא מופיע. סופר נדיר, נגיד B.
אוקיי, אז יש לי training data כמעט תמיד מופיע a ו c פעם ב מופיע B בסדר.
אחלה. אז כנראה שמה שהמודל יעריך זה שההסתברות לעבור מ a או b, c או מספר לא משנה ל b.
כנראה שהמודל יעריך אותה כמשהו די נמוך, נכון?
ויעדיף לשים את רוב המסה על A.
עובר לA או A עובר לסי ובשיא עובר לA בסי עובר לסי.
נכון, זה סביר להניח אם זה משהו כל כך נדיר בטריינינג.
אוקיי. אבל עכשיו בוא נניח שאותו קודקוד B כן אותו לייבל B.
מה שגם מצאנו בטריינינג data זה שכאשר כבר מופיע B הוא נוטה להישאר.
כן to press הסט הוא נוטה להישאר B.
כן, זאת אומרת אומנם להגיע ל B מאורע מאוד נדיר, אבל כשהוא כבר מופיע באותו פרומיל.
מיטרני הגזמת. פלס אז יש שם איזה סדרה של לא יודע.
10 B בסדר. אז יש לי הרבה מעברים B ביחס לכמות המים הכללית.
זה עדיין מספר קטן בסך הכל ביחס למספר המעברים הכולל בטריינינג Data, אבל ביחס לכמות ה B שמופיע הוא די גדול.
נכון כי רוב ה b מובילים ל b ולא למשהו אחר.
יפה, אז כנראה שאותו מודל תזכרו מכל קודקוד B כאן סכום המשקלים חייב להיות אחד.
סכום משקלים היוצאים אז איפה? כנראה הוא ישים את רוב המאסה הקריטית ביותר B נכון?
אז כנראה שזה. יהיה יחסית גדול יחסית, קרוב לאחד.
בסדר, נגיד 09. סתם אני זורק. אוקיי, אז אפס 9 הוא יהיה להישאר בB כן אפס 9 להישאר בB.
נגיד שזה קבוע כדי לפשט את הזה, אבל מראש ההסתברות לעבור אליו מA או מיסי היא נגיד אחד.
לא יודע, אמרנו פרומיל סתם, זאת אחד. אוקיי, עכשיו בוא נסתכל באיזה סיטואציה אנחנו נמצאים בה.
יש לנו שתי קטגוריות נפוצות נכון A, b, c.
בסדר שנגיד ההסתברות לעבור בין. אחת לשנייה היא יחסית גבוהה.
לא משנה, אולי לא מאוד גבוהה, אבל הנקודה היא יחסית גבוהה.
כלומר, אם בערך באזור החצי אפס 4 שיש בו נגיד חצי כדי לפשט את האנליזה בסדר, אז A אוהב להישאר בA ובשיא C אוהב להישאר בA או בשיא, אבל B לא.
אף אחד מהם לא עובר לעבור לB, אבל B אוהב להישאר עם עצמו. טוב, אז עכשיו בוא נסתכל על הרעיון שהמודל הזה משרה.
כן, זה לא בדיוק Prior כי זה לא מודל עסקי. זה לא מודל גן נרטיבי, זה מודל הסכם נתיבי.
אבל כאילו, בוא נחשוב על איזה הסתברויות כן, איזה מכפלת הסתברויות סדרות שונות מקבלות.
אוקיי, אז נגיד למשל ניקח את הסדרה A, C, a, B, c וכן הלאה.
כן, נגיד e באורך n. אז מה בערך ההסתברות שהיא תקבל?
כמה פעמים יצא כן בדיוק חצי בחזקת n.
נכון, כל מעבר נגיד הוא בערך חצי מקבל הסתברות בערך חצי בחזקת A.
בסדר. לעומת זאת, מה לגבי הסדרה נגיד a, c ואז b.
לא יודע. ואז אולי אפילו בוא נגיד עד הסוף.
סתם לשם הדוגמה. בסדר. אז מה קורה כאן?
גם אין. כן, אז חצי בשלישי כפול נגיד אפס תשע בחזקת n פחות שלוש בסדר.
עכשיו, כפי שאני מניח אתם כבר רואים.
ואם לא אתם יכולים לנסות במחשבון או משהו כזה כשאין הוא אפילו אפילו לא צריך להיות מאוד גדול.
כן, אבל כשהוא לא ממש קטן, איזה ההסתברויות האלה תהיה יותר גדולה שנייה בשנייה?
נכון, פשוט כי האקספוננט הגודל של האקספוננט הוא בעצם דבר שדי נכון מכריע.
איך? איך מתנהגת סדרה הנדסית על סדרה?
כן, סדרה הנדסית וזה. אוקיי, אז בעצם מה אנחנו מקבלים כאן?
מה שאנחנו מקבלים זה מודל שבעצם עושה איזשהו כפל חזק בין הנטייה של השרשרת להישאר נגיד הנטייה של השרשרת.
להעדיף צעדים שיש להם אנטרופיה נמוכה, כלומר להעדיף צעדים שהם קרובים ל דטרמיניסטי אם יש לה איזשהו בייס מובנה, ובעצם.
היא היא נוטה, לא יודע, כן נוטה לקשר בין שרשראות סבירות בתור פרי דיקציה, לבין שרשראות שהם יחסית צפויות.
כן, סדרות שהן יחסית צפויות יקבלו בהכרח כנראה הסתברות כן או ליחס בין ניקול יותר גדולה מאשר שרשראות פחות צפויות.
אוקיי, כלומר, יש כאן איזשהו נטייה לחבר בין כמה השרשרת.
היא צפוי. כמה מצבים הם צפויים, נגיד B. אני קורא לו מצב צפוי יחסית בגלל של רוב המסה שלו נשארת בB.
אוקיי, אז בעצם יש לה איזשהו בייס.
קוראים לזה לפעמים דה לייבל בייס. כן, לייבל בייס, שזה בדיוק אותו מקרה ששמתי כאן שיש אותו ברגע שאני מניח שזה מתן הרמל לאחד לוקאלית.
מתי לא נרצה אותו? יש בהחלט מקרים שבהם אנחנו לא היינו רוצים את הדבר הזה, שזה לא התנהגות מאוד סבירה מבחינתנו.
נגיד למשל לחשוב על נינט טייב אקוגני שם. אוקיי, בואו ניזכר.
אתם זוכרים את הבעיה של האינטרנט אותיות? עוד משהו לא?
אוקיי, מישהו מישהי שזה יכול להיות מעניין?
כן כן רוצים לשמוע מוזיקה?
כן, בדיוק. זיהוי של שמות, זיהוי של ישויות בטקסט שכתובות כשם.
ראינו את זה בשיעור הקודם, נגיד לזהות שפה מתחיל שם פה נגמר שם ולזהות שהוא מקטגוריה.
לא יודע מה יצירת אמנות, בן אדם, ארגון, מקום כן בחברה יפה, אבל בוא נניח שבני נדיר אקוגני.
יש לכם חלק מהקטגוריות שיש להם אורך. הם נוטות להיות ארוכות יותר מאחרות.
בסדר. מה זה אומר? זה אומר? זה אומר בעצם שנגיד קטגוריה A?
נגיד שיש אפילו שתי קטגוריות אפשריות בסדר ספרים ושמות של בני אדם טוב.
ונגיד שהספרים נוטים להיות הרבה יותר ארוכים מאשר בני אדם.
אז מה זה אומר שנייה אחת? אז מה שזה אומר זה שההסתברות של Continue.
אם אתם רואים שאתם לא כל כך ארוכים אז אני אזכיר לכם. שנייה אני אעלה את המצגת הזאת.
כן, בעצם נכון הבעיה של רוב מי שאנחנו חושבים עליה.
ככה נגיד, יש לנו שתי קטגוריות Company בלוקיישן, לא משנה בני אדם, מספרים לא נורא קריטי,
שתי קטגוריות רק לשם הפשטות, ואחת מהם נוטה להיות הרבה יותר ארוכה מהשנייה.
בסדר. איך נראית סדרה על איך תיראה סדרת הלייב? אז יש לנו בגדול במקרה כזה חמישה לייבלים אפשריים, אחד שאומר זה לא חלק משם.
שני שאומר זה התחלה של שם של קטגוריה A, המשך של שם של קטגוריה A, התחלה של שם קטגוריה B, המשך של שם קטגוריה B.
נכון. עכשיו מה זה אומר תכלס? הקטגוריה A הרבה יותר ארוכה.
שמות של הרבה יותר ארוכים מאשר של קטגוריה B. מה זה אומר מבחינת הסתברויות מעבר גבוה?
איפה? כלומר איזה מעברים הם סבירים יותר או פחות רוצים להבטיח?
אוקיי, אז בגדול אנחנו רואים אז באלה ארוכים יותר ההסתברות כן.
קטגוריה שיש בה שמות ממש ארוכים, נגיד שמות של ספרים.
משהו כזה. אז ההסתברות של Continue book בהינתן Continue book היא גבוהה גבוהה נכון יגווע.
כי אני נוטה להמשיך. אם כבר התחלתי שם של ספר ניתן להמשיך.
גם start book ההסתברות לכל תינוק הוא כקבוע.
כלומר, וזה נכון.
בין אם Book הוא קטגוריה פי מיליון פחות סבירה או פחות נפוצה בטריינינג Data.
מאשר person או להפך. נכון, בכל מקרה זה לא משנה.
ההסתברות של Continue book בהינתן continue book היא תהיה גבוהה במקרה כזה.
אוקיי, וזה לא דוגמה מומצאת. כן, אפילו לקחתי דוגמה קצת קיצונית אבל.
כן, אבל אולי נחמדה. אז נגיד למשל יש סופרת בשם E לוקהארט שאלה שמות אמיתיים של הספרים שלה.
אז למשל, אם יש לכם. ספציפית באותו קורפוס רשימה של בעיקר נטייה לדבר על אותה סופרת או סופרים דומים לה מבחינת הנטיות, הנטיות, השיעור שלהם.
אז אתם רואים שזה יכול להיות מאוד מאוד ארוך. כן, The Boyfriend לי גיי זי לבן שבעיקר פוינט מנסה false אבל אין מובי אולי ובסוגריים זה גם חלק מהשם.
רובי אוליבר פסיק אחד אז החלק השני.
כן כן, זה לא אני הוספתי. זה חלק מהשם. בקיצור, מה שאני מתכוון לומר בסדר, זה קצת דוגמה היתולית, אבל בהחלט הדברים האלה קורים.
בהחלט יכול להיות שה קטגוריות מסוימות יהיו הרבה יותר ארוכות מאשר קטגוריות אחרות.
אחרות יהיו קצרות, והדבר הזה יכניס בייס מהותי בעצם לטובתם, אפילו אם התדירות שלהם בטריינינג די תהיה משמעותית יותר נמוכה.
בסדר, אז איך אנחנו פותרים את זה? כי אני לא הבנתי למה זה בעיה, כי מראש ההסתברות של.
ידענו שהוא לא מתנהל נכון, אבל בעצם אנחנו מדברים פה על שרשרת מרקוב, נכון?
ובגלל שזאת שרשרת מרקוב אז אז ההסתברות המשותפת היא מכפלה של הסתברויות מותנות לוקאלית.
נכון, נגיד אם זה by גרם, אם זה בייקר מודל בייט שנייה אחת אני אסמן של הבא גם אם יהיה מ.
אז ההסתברות תהיה פשוט מכפלה של ההסתברויות המעברים הלוקח להיות 1 בהינתן הקודם, אם זה טריק או שניים בסדר, אבל זה עדיין יהיה כנראה חלון די מצומצם.
נכון, אבל עדיין זה זה. זה לא יענה על כל הרצף, כי זה בדיוק הנחת המרכזיות.
נכון, זה בדיוק הנחת המקובעות שאתה שההסתברות של Wii בהינתן כל הקודמים ההסתברות של WiFi בהינתן זה שמידי קודם כן,
אם זה ביתר מודל לדוגמה או שניים זה טריגר אז בקיצור הנחת המרחב מהנחת המקומיות.
אתה יורש את זה שבעצם סבירות כן accounts is likely.
אז אצלו כל סגמנט בעצם נכון ברגע שהיא הנחה ככלל לא נכונה.
נכון לגבי שפה, אבל השתמשנו בה כי ההנחה הזאת עוזרת לנו לעשות אינפלציה.
טוויטר בלי בלעשות למידה יעילה ודברים כאלה.
אבל אנחנו עכשיו מיד נראה שאנחנו יכולים להחליש את ההנחה הזאת, לא להניח מקוביות אלא משהו קצת יותר חלש ממר קוביות,
מה שלא יגרור את הלייבל בייס הזה ובכל זאת ליהנות מהיתרונות של היעילות.
בסדר, קצת, יש לי בעיה. למה בעצם?
אז אולי תסביר לי בוא נגיד באמת שאנחנו במקרה הזה של הנדנדה תראה קוגניטיבית כן, שהצגתי קודם.
זאת אומרת, אנחנו במקרה הזה.
ונניח לשם הדיון כן של לוקיישן באותו קורפוס נוטים להיות נורא ארוכים, ולעומת זאת Companies נוטים להיות נורא קצרים בני מילה אחת.
אוקיי. ניקח, ניקח את זה לקיצון. בסדר, ועכשיו אתה הולך ואתה מאמן על טריינינג Data שלך.
ומה שאתה שם לב בטרנינג data שלך זה ש companies הם תכלס פי אלף יותר נפוצים מאשר לוקיישן.
בסדר, אני פשוט פי אלף יותר. הלייבל של Company הוא פי אלף יותר נפוץ ככה.
בסדר, אוקיי, אז בגדול, בהנחה שהם טריינינג data שלך הוא מספיק גדול,
ובהינתן שזה ההנחה המקובלת אצלנו כרגע שאתה מה שנקרא באין דומיין setting, כלומר שהטקסט database טריינינג data מגיעים מאותה התפלגות.
נכון שזו הנחה מקובלת בסופר בייס כאילו פאק learning וזה.
אז מה אתה מצפה שבתא סט יהיה היחס בין הנפוצות של Company ושל לוקיישן דומה?
נכון גם בערך פי אלף נכון בערך פי אלף יותר companies מאשר location.
אוקיי, אבל אז אתה ניגש ואתה לומד את המודל.
מר קובי טוב ביותר שהצלחת אבל הוא Minimum.
כן למדת הימים ההם ועכשיו אתה ניגש לתייג את הטסט Data שלך.
אז בוא נסתכל מה המצב אצלך. אתה ככל הנראה כן, כמובן הכל תלוי בפיצ'רים וכדומה.
אבל כאילו בגדול. בגדול מה שאתה מצאת זה שההסתברות אפריורית, כלומר הגיוני גרם distribution.
נגיד למשל של Company הוא פי המון הוויט שנותן לו נכון לפיצ'ר של יוני גם פי המון יותר גדול לסטארט Company continue company נגיד טוב continue company.
אולי לא. אם זה בן מילה אחת, לא משנה אם זה שתיים אז גם condition company מאשר ללוקיישן לסטארט לוקיישן.
וקוונטין הוא לוקיישן.
נכון, הוא הרבה הרבה יותר גדול, יפה ואבל אתה גם ראית שביחס למה שבעצם הסתברויות המעבר, כלומר הבית גרם Distribution על הלייבלים בשביל Continue?
זאת אומרת של Continue לוקיישן להופיע אחרי סטארט לוקיישן או של Continue לוקיישן להופיע אחרי Continue לוקיישן זה מאוד גבוה.
זאת אומרת, בהינתן שה הלייבל הקודם שלך הוא כבר לוקיישן, יש לך סיכוי מאוד גבוה.
ועכשיו אוקיי, עכשיו חמוש בוי צהל בפיצ'רים האלה אתה ניגש לתייג את ה טריינינג Example שלך.
את הטסט Example שולחים לך כן את הטסט Example שלך.
ועכשיו אתה אומר אוקיי, אז מה שאני עושה עקרונית מה שפיטר פיטר בי עושה את זה בצורה יותר יעילה, אבל מהותית מה שהוא עושה זה מוצא את הסדרה הסבירה ביותר.
נכון, בהינתן Wait האלה שמצאת, ועכשיו הוא שוקל כאן שתי שרשראות אפשריות.
נגיד כן, שוקל הרבה, אבל סתם ניקח דוגמה.
כן. אחת מהם היא כזאת שבה שנראית כמו ההסתברות של Y אחד.
כן, בואו נסמן את זה לשם פשטות. נגיד שיש לי רק שתי קטגוריות למרות שיש לי 4.
רק לשם הפשטות. אז נגיד אחד זה וואי 1 שווה AA?
או בעצם אולי צריך שלוש קטגוריות, נגיד גם?
אז נגיד אני מסתכל על וואי אחד שווה AA.
בהינתן וואי אפס start כפול האיקסים תמיד אני מציע להם.
וההסתברות של וואי שתיים שווה AA בהינתן וואי אחד שווה.
וההסתברות של וואי שלוש שווה נאן בהינתן.
וואי שתיים שווה וכן הלאה. כל פעם מה שחשוב לי זה שהוא עובר בין none לa.
אוקיי הוא מחליף איזה? Company כן זה היותר נפוץ.
אז מה שאתה רואה זה שבגלל שהרבה פעמים קומפני הם קצרים אז הרבה פעמים הם עוברים לנמען נכון?
אם זה אחד, אם הם באורך אחד אז הם תמיד עוברים אפילו לנדן.
ואם זה נאן אז כמה זה אולי צריך? פעם זה נשאר NAND, לפעמים זה Company אבל לא באיזה צורה מאוד דרמטית.
צורה מאוד דטרמיניסטית. אז סתם נניח לצורך הדוגמה, העניין ששניהם הם בערך חצי.
אוקיי, או אולי אפס שש אפשר, ולא משנה אם כולם באזור הזה שם, אז הסדרה הזאת מבחינת ההסתברויות, מתנהגת בערך כמו חצי בחזקת אורך הסדרה.
אוקיי, ועכשיו אביתר שוקל גם הוא שוקל את כל האופציות.
כן, אז הוא שוקל גם אופציה אחרת שהיא האופציה שבה וואי אחד נגיד שווה אולי צפרדע.
וואי 2 שווה לפי. יונתן רועי אחד שווה AA ואז y שלוש שווה be בהינתן y שתיים שווה be.
וממשיך ככה ונגיד אפילו נשאר עד הסוף.
B בשם ההגזמה. אוקיי, אז הסדרה הזאת.
יש בה פקטור אחד שהוא כנראה מאוד נמוך. כן, הדבר הזה.
אולי נגיד על פיט. לא יודע מה. כן, הוא ממש קטן.
מה כבר הסיכוי לראות B בהינתן איי או סיכוי נורא קטן על פיט?
אבל מה כאן כל הזמן מכפיל אותו במספרים שהם קרובים לאחד או הפחות הרבה יותר גדולים מחצי?
כן, אפס 9 לא משנה מה. אז כנראה שאם הסדרה היא לא מאוד קצרה אתה תעדיף את זה.
כן. בעצם יש לך איזשהו בייס שגורם לך להעדיף דברים דטרמיניסטי בגלל שהיו קרובים לטרמינל מניפסטים בגלל שכן.
כן, אתה מעדיף צלעות שהן קרובות, שהן קרובות דטרמיניסטית.
כי בעצם, אפילו אם prior אליהם הוא נמוך, כי ה prior אליהם מתבטא בזה שהצלע שמכניסה אותך לאזור ה דטרמיניסטי הזה בגרף היא קטנה, אבל אתה כנראה יכול לפצח.
אם זה לא ממש ממש ממש קטן, אתה כנראה יכול לפצות על הקנס שאתה משלם על ידי זה שתפיל בהסתברות גדולות.
אבל בוא נגיד שהיה לך עכשיו שלא היה לך את האילוץ הזה.
כן, כלומר ראית? זה לא היה מר קובי. כלומר, זה לא היה מסתכם לאחד, אלא פשוט היה לך פה משקלים חיובים כלשהם.
אז על פניו היית יכול לדאוג לזה שגם הצלע הזאת תהיה קטנה, וגם הצלע הזאת אולי תהיה גדולה ביחס לצלע הזאת,
אבל שתיהן יהיו קטנות בערך מוחלט, וזאת דווקא תהיה יחסית גדולה.
בערך. כן, אז אתה משוחרר מאילוצים.
עכשיו המשחק שלנו כאן הוא שבעצם אם אני לגמרי מראש, זה לא שהכנסנו את המר קוביות הזאת כדי לעשות לעצמנו חיים קשים, הכנסנו אותה כי אז כן סיפקה לנו ערך.
כן, הערך שהיא סיפרה לנו היא בזה שהיא בעצם פירקה את הדבר המורכב הזה שלא ידענו איך להתמודד איתו.
שזה לתת התפלגות משותפת על אן, בעצם על סדרות שיש מספר אקספוננציאלי שלהם.
אז היא פירקה אותנו, את זה לך לחלקים יותר קטנים ואז גם היינו יכולים ללמוד באופן יעיל וגם היינו יכולים לבצע עסק באופן יעיל.
אז בעצם השאלה היא איך לא לגמרי מוותרים על הכל ונותנים לסכום רינג function להיות מה שאתה רוצה,
שזה אולי נהדר מבחינת אקספרסיביות, אבל גרוע מבחינת למידות.
אבל בכל זאת קצת לשחרר. כן כן.
כל הסיפור עם מוטיבציה לא ממש מעניין אותי במשחק בלקן ביט בוקס.
נכון באמת. ספציפית בסרטון הזה אני מפספס משהו.
אני? מה שאפשר. שהוא בתוך שהוא.
הבעיה היא שהחלון לקונטקסט שלך. הוא קצר מדי או קצר.
אז מה כשאתה נכנס לקטגוריה? זה מזכיר לי את הקולקציה שכל הזמן זוכרת שהיא נכנסת ממש ממש.
זה לא עניין כלכלי שם כרגע צריך. כלומר אני מרשה דגלים של 8 ספרים עד 10 ב 10.
אני מבין למה. כן, אז אתה יכול לתפור אם יש לך.
ככל שיש לך. ככל שיש לך הנחות יותר חזקות על.
על הדאטה שלך, אז אתה יכול להתמודד באמת עם מגוון יחסית גדול של דברים.
אני חושב שמה שיהיה נחמד בקשר שאני תכף אציג, זה שמסתבר שוב, אבל זה לגמרי שאלה פרקטית, אבל מסתבר שלהרבה צרכים פרקטיים.
החלשה הדי קטנה הזאת אומרת הרי נכסיה העדינה הזאת בפוליסה שלהם ימים היא כבר מספיק אקספרסיבית כדי בחלק מהמקרים לתת לך ערך מוסף משמעותי.
אבל אתה צודק שהיא לא פתרון. כן, בהחלט.
ככל שאתה יש לך הנחות יותר, בוא נאמר כזה ככל שאתה מסוגל יותר לתפור חליפה ספציפית עבור הבעיה שלך, על סמך הנחות שיש לך יסוד חזק להאמין שהן נכונות.
אז כן, אז אתה יכול גם הרבה פעמים לעשות יותר טוב מאשר להשתמש בשיטות גנריות.
אתה אומר למרות שזה פתרון.
אני מעדיף לעשות את זה להנחות שלי, של המודל שלא כל כך הטיב שלו מאשר רציתי לעשות נעים לכל באי, לפעמים לפעמים, אבל זה באמת תלוי בסיטואציה.
לפעמים אתה מעדיף את זה, אתה יודע, יש כל מיני דברים. גם עד לא מזמן היה משהו שנקרא עלויות פיתוח ותחזוק קוד.
נכון שאנשים לא רצו להשתמש באלגוריתמים מורכבים, כי אתה עשית דרך קשה אחרי זה להעביר אותם ויוצר לגאסי,
עסקאות ומתחלף המתכנת ואף אחד לא יודע איך להתמודד עם זה.
אני אומר את זה בצחוק. כן, כי כאילו כיום אולי בוט פשוט תתחזק את הקוד, אבל כנראה שעדיין שוקלים שיקולים מעין זה.
מעבר זה השיקול די מרכזי נגד להגדיר מודלים עם הרבה חלקים נעים.
אוקיי, אז בוא נצא להפסקה ונחזור חצי דקה.
היועץ לא. לא.
אני הולך לא כלום.
רק את. אבל.
איזה. איפה?
הדבר הזה? טוב נמשיך.
אז מה הוא? מה יותר אלכסה ציה מדוברת שתאפשר לנו במידה מסוימת להחליש את הנחת הקוביות, אבל בלי לפגוע באופן משמעותי ביכולת שלנו לבצע למידה אפקטיביים.
אז הצעה אחת לזה שזכתה לפופולריות רבה מאוד והייתה קצת תקופת יובש,
אבל עכשיו גם אני רואה שהיא חוזרת ואפילו כל מיני חברות כמו אופן AI שלרוב מתעניינות רק ברשתות נוירונים ומקסימום פולסים גרדיאנט.
ראיתי שהם פרסמו לאחרונה משהו עם Craft. אין רק אודישן רנדומלי.
אוקיי, אז בקיצור, ואנחנו נראה אינסטנט ספציפי של משהו.
האינסטנט של המודל בהקשר של סיקוונס Model Scan של באמת רצפים של של פרדי קצוות שיש תלות ביניהם.
והרעיון הוא פשוט הרעיון, אומר במקום להניח שההסתברות של הY של שרשרת הY מתפרקת כשרשרת מרקוב, מספיק לנו להניח שהיא מתפרקת כמכפלה של פקטורים חיוביים.
אוקיי, אבל שלאו דווקא מתערבלים לוקאלית לאחד.
כלומר, במילים אחרות אנחנו יכולים.
מספיק לנו לדרוש שההסתברות של סדרה של Y מתקבלת כמכפלה על אקספוננציאלית של אזכורים כן על אקספוננציאלית של סכומים לא נורמלים.
זאת אומרת, יכולים לקחת איזשהו ערך חיובי,
והדבר היחידי שאנחנו צריכים לדאוג לו זה שבסופו של דבר כל הפי Y בהינתן איקס יהווה התפלגות כי לא כל אחד פקטורים לכשעצמו יהווה התפלגות,
כלומר לא מסתכם לאחד אלא הסכימה על פני כל המסלולים האפשריים על פני כל סדרות ה y האפשריות.
היא צריכה להסתכם לאחד וזהו. אין דרישות נוספות מעבר לזה.
במקרה שלהם מימין, הדרישה הגלובלית מתקיימת כפועל יוצא כמסקנה מהניהול לוקאלי.
כן, אם זה מנורמה לוקאלית אז גם די קל.
אתם יכולים לעשות את זה כתרגיל פשוט בבית. לראות שבעצם גם הסכימה על ההסתברויות של כל המסלולים מתנהלת גלובלית.
כלומר סכום ההסתברויות של כל המסלולים הוא אחד באמ, אבל CF אומר למה אני לא צריך לדרוש את זה לוקאלית?
מספיק לי לדרוש את זה גלובלית. כלומר, יהיה לי פה את הפקטורים האלה ויהיה גורם נירמול גלובלי.
כלומר יהיה לי גורם נירמול שסוכם על פני כל סדרות האפשריות של Y לפני כל המספר אקספוננציאלי הזה של סדרות של Y.
על המשקל של המסוק אמר על מכפלת המעברים הלא מנוהלים באותו מסלול.
עכשיו מה שנדרש להוכיח נדרש להוכיח כאן כי בעצם יש כאן שלוש טענות.
עכשיו כן, שתיים מהם אנחנו נוכיח, והשלישית היא בעצם טענה אמפירית.
כן, שפשוט יוצאת מניסוי וטעייה, וכפי שנראה אם מתקיים בפועל.
הטענה הראשונה והשנייה שנראה כאן זה שבעצם אנחנו עדיין יכולים ללמוד גם במודל הזה בצורה יעילה, והשנייה היא שאנחנו מסוגלים לבצע היסק בצורה יעילה.
השלישית היא שהולכת להציע זאת. היא להרבה צרכים מספקת.
כן, כלומר. יש איזשהו ערך מוסף ולהניח את זה מעבר להנחת המד קוביות של העניין.
כן. אז בשביל שאנחנו. שמעתם נכון?
אם כן, אז יש כאן בהחלט הנחה. כן, ודאי לא כל. לא כל התפלגות על פני ה y מסוגלת כן יכולה להתפרק באופן הזה.
כן. זאת אומרת, אפשר בקלות נגיד אם תיקח את הגריל התפלגות אקראית.
כן, על בוא נגיד אפילו תקבע את האורך.
כן, תגיד, יש לי עכשיו מודל על שרשראות באורך 10?
יש לי שלוש קטגוריות. כן, אז יש לי שלוש בחזקת עשר שרשראות אפשריות.
ונגיד את הגריל איזה שהוא מולטי נון על פני ה 3 בחזקת 10.
זה לא מספר כל כך כל כך גבוה. אפשר בהחלט לעשות את זה.
אתה תראה שהסיכוי שלך לקלוע למשהו שמתפרק בצורה כל כך יפה הוא פחות או יותר אפס.
כן, הוא מאוד קטן אז זה בהחלט הנחה משמעותית.
מצד שני היא יותר חלשה מהנחת המרת קוביות.
ולמען האמת היא זאת אומרת צריך.
טוב אוקיי, יש כאן איזה שהיא נקודה עדינה שאני לא רוצה להיכנס אליה, שיש שאלה האם שיש עליה תשובה כן,
אבל פשוט זה נראה לי נושא לקורס יותר מתקדם מזה שהיא השאלה האם מחלקת היפותזות יותר גדולה?
כלומר האם כל? כל?
שרשרת שניתן לייצג אותה באמצעות Cross.
ניתן גם לייצג אותה באמצעות My name.
אוקיי, אז תשימו לב שזאת טענה אחרת מאשר השאלה האם cars הוא מודל יותר טוב לצרכים פרקטיים מאשר אממ,
כי זה שניתן לייצג משהו, לעשות פורטל ומכריזה ולייצג אותו בצורה אחרת על ידי אמינם, לא אומר שיש לו בהכרח.
זאת אומרת שקל ללמוד אותו. קל להגדיר פונקציית פיצ'רים שתהיה אפקטיבית, לא כן באותו באותה.
זאת אומרת שניתן ללמוד בצורה אפקטיבית דומה.
בעצם תחת מה לא ניסחתי את עצמי?
טוב, זה שלשתי מחלקות היפותזות יש את אותה אקספרסיביות במובן שכל אחת ניתן להביע לגבי כמו כמו השנייה,
לא אומר שלה שהאחת היא לא יותר טובה מהאחרת עבור צרכים מסוימים בגלל שהלמידה היא משתנה.
כן? אז כן, זה מעניין, אבל לפני כן כל הליבה כן.
אז היא הסכימה בתורות. אתה יודע על כל מה שאמרת בדיוק?
אנחנו תכף נראה את זה. אוקיי, אנחנו תכף נראה את זה. יפה.
אז בוא נתחיל. כן, אתם יודעים מה?
אולי נתחיל בהערה פשוט לפני שנצלול ככה ל training craft שהוא יהיה אתם תראו טיפה טיפונת מורכב.
נשאל דבר ראשון את השאלה יותר פשוטה מה קורה לגבי עסק?
כן, בעצם לגבי עסק תשימו לב שאנחנו לא צריכים לשנות שום דבר.
בעצם. בואו ניזכר בביתר בית אלגוריתם במסחר בביתר ויאהבו את מה שהגדרנו אותו בהקשר של.
כן, כמו שהגדרנו אותו בהקשר של Min. אוקיי, אז בהקשר שלהם ימים אני אזכיר לכם, הגדרנו בעצם את הסכומים, את המסלולים החלקיים, כן,
את הרישיון של מסלולים ואת המשקל שלהם, פשוט כי מכפלת הצלעות על נגיד K המעברים הראשונים.
אוקיי, ואז מה שאמרנו שאנחנו בעצם רוצים לעשות זה לפרק את בעיית האינפורמציה כללית לתתי בעיות.
תתי הבעיות האלה הם מציאת המסלול הכבד ביותר, כלומר מציאת המסלול שהם ממקסם את ההסתברות עבור ראשון באורך שמסתיים בקטגוריית חיובי.
אוקיי, וזאת עבור כל אורך קיי וכל האופציות וכל האופציות.
לוי. אמרנו שאנחנו יכולים לרשום לכתוב טבלה.
כן, טבלה של תכנון דינמי. פיקי יעקובי שיחזיק בכל תא את העסק, כלומר את המקסימום, לא את הארגון.
הסכם שעושה ממש את המקסימום, כלומר את ההסתברות המקסימלית של סדרת דגים שמסתיימת אחרי K צעדים.
אם התגיות יעבוד ושאפשר למלא את אותו תנאי פשוט על ידי אלגוריתם דינמי, נכון?
כן, שניתן למלא את פי בעצם על ידי אלגוריתם דינמי שבו כן המסלול.
אפס סדר פשוט יוגדרו להיות אחד, ועבור והדרך שבה אני עולה ברגע שיש לי כבר רמה אחת.
כן, עבור k שווה אפס או עבור אחד או באופן כללי עבור key מינוס אחד.
איך אני עולה לרמה K?
אז מה שאני צריך זה פשוט למקסם על פני כל האפשרויות לתא האופטימלי במקום k מינוס שתיים על המסלול האופטימלי באורך k מינוס אחד שנגמר בתיוג.
כלומר נגמר באחת התגיות האלה ואחריו יו כפול המעבר בין V.
המעבר בין טיול לבין לבין V כן, אז אפשר למלא את זה באופן דינאמי.
מה שחשוב לצרכינו כאן זה שבמה ממש לא לא משתמש את הנוסחה הזאת, ולמעשה גם ההוכחה של הנכונות של זה למטה ההחלפה וכל זה לא משתמשת.
בעקרון בניהול כן בדיוק זה מה שאמרת בלב.
אה נכון דבר ראשון בלייבלים הקודמים. נכון, זה בכלל מה שבהחלט מה שבכלל מאפשר לנו לעשות ויתר ביט זה זה שזה כן מתפרק בצורה
שהמסלול האופטימלי באורך הכי מורכב ממסלולים אופטימליים באורך קיים מינוס אחד,
וזה נובע באמת מזה שזה מתפרק למכפלה כזאת.
כן למכפלה של גורמים שכל אחת מהם תלויה רק בשק שלושת התגיות האחרונות.
אבל מה שאנחנו לא מסתמכים כאן זה על זה שהדבר הזה מסתכם בהם, אם הם על פני קולבים ולכל טבעי ויהיו למעשה אחד לאחד.
כן, אנחנו לא מסתמכים בזה בשום צורה. זה יעבוד בדיוק באותו אופן, ואתם מוזמנים כתרגיל פשוט לשכנע את עצמכם וזהו.
ממש לכתוב את ההוכחה אם תרצו שזה לא משתמש בשום נקודה בהנחה הזאת הוא ממילא גם עשיר,
אך מרגע שהוא מתפרק למכפלה על פקטורים לוקאלי, אם כן אין עם זה ביג גרם.
אז פקטורים כן. שני גורמים Try גרם עם שלושה וכן הלאה.
ברגע שזה מתפרק למכפלה של פקטורים לא קטנים ניתן להפעיל את טוויטר בדיוק באותו אופן.
כן? אוקיי, אמרת את זה קצת פספסתי.
את יכול להסביר את זה? גם העובדה שאנחנו.
בהצהרה. של המייסד של הלייבל באינסטגרם.
כי בעצם ממה נבע הלייבל? בעיה של הלייבל BIOS נבע מזה שהדרך שאנחנו נתנו משקולות לצלעות היא.
בעצם כזאת שמחייבת אותנו שהסכום על כל הצלעות היוצאות מהקודקוד יהיה אחד.
בשיא הערב כבר אין את האילוץ הזה. כן, מה שאומר שבאופן עקרוני עבור דאבליו מתאים כן, עבור סט משקולות מתאים הצלע הזאת יכולה לקבל נגיד הסתברות של אלפית כן,
והצלע הזאת היא והצלע הזאת היא סדרות של מיליונית נגיד אוקיי, ואז מה שיקרה זה שהן והצלעות האלה עדיין יכולות לקבל.
נגיד לא יודע ערך גבוה, ומה שנקרא זה שתי הרצפים האלו כבר לא יתנהגו בערך כמו אפס 9 בחזקת אן לעומת אלה שיתנהגו כמו חצי בחזקת n.
אלה עכשיו יתנהגו כאיזשהו האקספוננט שנובע מהם המשקולות שיוגדרו אולי קטן, אולי גדול וזה מוגדר על ידי איזשהו צומת אחר.
של הליין של לייבלים נדירים לא יופיעו בכלל.
הבעיה שספר. גם פעמים מגיע.
יכול להמשיך ברצף. זאת הייתה הבעיה.
נכון שהיום אני עושה את המשרד שלי ואז אני יכול לבטל את העובדה ש.
לוקאלית. זה נכון שזה הרבה יותר סביר להישאר בספר, אבל כל הסיפור של ספר הוא לא ספק נכון.
כן, כי הוא לא ויתר. די, הוא לא ויתר.
באמת רוצה את האופטימיות הגלובלית הגלובלי.
כרגע לא בטוח אם הוא גם. ואם הם חושבים שזה לא בסדר אז אתה יכול לומר שאתה רוצה אולי להכניס לתוך הליברליות שלך איזשהו ביסטרו מאיזושהי דרך?
נגיד, אם אתה חושב שאולי בעצם מה שאתה אומר זה שיכול להיות שם מקסימום ליברליות Function.
כן, אין כאן רובע לייט להיות מה שאתה אומר, שיכול להיות שהמקסימום לייט להיות Function לצרכיך הוא לא.
כן, הוא לא. לא בדיוק מתאים, כי היית רוצה לתת אולי איזשהו ביס איזשהו פרי או לזה לייבלים נדירים?
לא יודע. הם אמורים לקבל יותר ממה שפשוט הם יקבלו.
יקבלו באופן הזה. בסדר, אז אוקיי, אז אפשר עוד כמה.
אנחנו לא דיברנו על הכנסה של כל מיני. כן, כל מיני גורמים נוספים, כאלה שאמורים לתקן כל מיני רגולרי זה הציות.
אבל בגדול גם כאן אפשר להכניס כל מיני ריגול, אריזה, ציוד שזה עולם שלם.
אבל. אבל הנקודה היא שעל פניו זה לא שלא לא ניתן לייצג.
למעשה, בהחלט ניתן אפילו לייצג בדיוק את אותם התפלגויות כמו שהימין מציג.
פשוט יש כאן. כן כן, בדיוק.
זה לא בהכרח כן. זאת אחלה של הטיעונים בכלל.
אבל אולי מקרה הרבה יותר קרוב להתפתחות של.
כן, זה בעצם השיק. זה בעצם השאיפה. כן, כי בעצם יכול להיות שיהיה לך יותר קל.
בעצם, מה אתה עושה כאן? הרי מה אתה עושה ברגע שאתה מגדיר מודל פרמטרי?
כן, זאת אומרת, אתה מגדיר פה משפחה של התפלגויות.
אם הדאטה עצמו מראש בנוי לפי אותה התפלגות, ובהנחה שמתקיימת במקרה כאן שהבעיה שבעיית מקסימום likely רוט היא בעיה,
כי רק אז אתה תוכל באמת בדיוק לבטא את ההתפלגות האמיתית.
בהינתן מספיק דוגמאות, כן, באמת אתה תתכנס.
המקסימום Likely הוא להתכנס להתפלגות האמיתית שממנה נדגם הדאטה.
אוקיי, איפה הבעיה? הבעיה היא שבהרבה מקרים המודל שלך בגלל שמצב הדברים הוא הוא כתיב.
כן, אתה לא אומר שכל ההתפלגות אז. אז בעצם מה שאתה תעשה זה זה.
זה תקרב את ההתפלגות האמיתית של הדאטה והיא תהיה לך שגיאה שנובעת משתי מקורות.
מקור אחד. זה באמת זה שהדגם שלך הוא לא אינסופי ולכן אין מה לעשות.
יש לך איזשהו רעש שנובע מהמיטה ויש לך דבר נוסף שזה בטח למדתם על זה באי מייל.
כן, על בעצם הרעש שנובע מכך שאתה לא יכול לייצג את ההתפלגות האמיתית של הדאטה באמצעות מחלקת היפותזות שלך, ואז השאלה היא לאן אתה תתכנס?
כן, ויכול להיות שיש לך סיבה להאמין שאתה תתכנס למקום לא טוב, כי אתה יודע משהו על הדאטה ואז אתה יכול להכניס איזשהו גורם ריקול אריזתם מנסה לתקן את זה.
זה בגדול. המשחק הוא משחק מאוד מורכב באופן כללי כן, בסדר, יפה, אז אנחנו רוצים למקסם את הלייקים.
אז מהו הלייק לראות? יש לנו כרגיל סופר וי Settings.
כן, יש לנו טרי, נגזר פרס סדרות.
כזכור לכם סופר סקיפ זה דוגמת אימון.
כן, זה האינדקס של איזה דוגמת אימון זאת גדול.
דוגמאות אימון Subscribe זה. זוכרים?
איזה בדיחה כאן. לא במקרה כאן.
מה זה? וואי מה זה? וואי סופר סקריפט איי Subscribe?
מה? כן. לדוגמה מי?
בדיוק. כן בדיוק. אז וואי סאבסקרייב.
סופר סקריפט איי הוא בעצם school solution.
כן, כי עכשיו אנחנו מדברים על data. מתוייג נכון? הוא בעצם הלייבל האמיתי של האי.
אינדקס האי כן של הדיקציה. סליחה בדוגמה האיי בשנות במשפט האי בשרשרת האינטרנט.
אוקיי, אז טיפה מבלבל, אבל מקווה שתתרגלו.
אז בעצם אנחנו יכולים לכתוב את הלייט נייט function למכפלה על פני כל דוגמאות.
האימון בעצם זה condition הלייט נייט כמובן, ולכתוב את זה בצורה אפית המקובלת.
מכפלה על המעברים חלקי גורם נרמול במקרה כאן כתבתי by גראם.
כמובן שאפשר גם לכתוב סדרים יותר גבוהים אם רוצים.
וגורם אני אומר לו סכום על פני כל השרשראות האפשריות של כאן.
אתם רואים שכתבתי וואי וואי ג'יי מינוס אחד ולא וואי סופר סקריפט.
איי ג'יי ווי סופר סקריפט איי ג'יי מינוס אחד.
למה? בדיוק זה סכימה על כל האפשרויות ולא זה הנכון.
אם זה עזר נכון אז הייתי סופר סטים. בסדר אז אני מקווה שאין מוטציה.
היא ברורה קצת, לוקח זמן להתרגל אליה אז אי אפשר.
כן. איך זה הפיצ'ר Function לא האינדקסים אבל כן.
ג'יי הוא בעצם האינדקס בתוך הסדרה.
כן, אז נגיד כאן כמו כאן. וואי אחד זה הלייבל של הראשון בסדרה.
וואי אפס אפס בסידרה וכן הלאה.
בסדר, זה נשאר אותו דבר. אבל עכשיו יש לי הרבה שרשראות נכון?
נגיד משפטים או פסקאות או לא משנה מה אז ויש לי והם מתויגים גם אז איך אני מסמן אותם?
אז יש לי איקס סופר סקריפט. איי זה אומר C, סדרת המילים נגיד האיי, סדרת הטוורקינג זי ווי סופר סקריפט I זה סדרת הלייבלים הנכונים עבורה.
קיבלתי אותה, היא נמדדת. ואם אני סתם כותב וואי ג'יי בלי סופר סקריפט הכוונה היא שזה משתנה כבוי.
כן שאני סוכם עליו או מכפיל עליו או משהו בסדר. עוד שאלות.
יפה. אז זאת הפונקציה שאני רוצה למקסם. אני רוצה למצוא את הפרמטרים של המודל שמקדמים.
מה הם הפרמטרים של המודל? הטאבלט נכון, וקטור המשקל או איזשהו וקטור ממשי של?
הפרשנים עדיין. בין הפיצ'רים הרבים שלך.
לשדרג? כן, זה בדיוק באותה מוטציה כמו שעשינו קודם.
תראי, עקרונית המתימטיקה לא מחייבת אותך לשום צורה שהיא לא מחייבת אותך לפי תארים בינאריים יכולים יכולים להיות ממשיים.
זה לא חייב להיות בלוקים, זה יכול להיות סתם סדרה אקראית של פיצ'רים שנראים לך רלוונטיים דה פקטו.
מה שמשתמשים זה דברים בינאריים לפי Patterns כאלה.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו כרגיל אוהבים לקחת לוק.
יותר קל לגזור לוק, אז אנחנו לוקחים את הלוג Like להוריד.
המכפלות הופכות לסכומים האקספוננט כשלוקחים לו לוג הופך פשוט כן לסכום כן למה שכתוב האקספוננט.
כלומר מה שיש לנו זה סכימה על פני כל דוגמאות.
האימון סכימה על פני כל המעברים של הפיצ'ר function של הלייבלים הנכונים.
כן של המעבר הזה. וואי ג'יי סופר סקריפט. I מסכת סופר script i כפול וקטור המשקולות פחות לוג של גורם נרמול הגלובלי שהוא קיים.
אחד כזה לכל סיקוונס לכל, דוגמת אימון לכל, לכל שרשרת והוא כן כזכור קודם פשוט סכימה על כל על כל השרשראות, על הסכומים שלהם, מכפלת המעברים.
כרגיל במודלים לוג לינאריים והמודל הזה הוא לגמרי מודל לא לינארית.
הגודל לא לינארי, אולי טיפה משונה במובן הזה שיש לו המון המון תגיות אפשריות.
כן, יש לו כמספר המסלולים.
כן, כלומר מספר הקטגוריות השונות בחזקת האורך העסיק אואנס קטגוריות אפשריות.
אבל, ויש לו צורה מיוחדת, כן, הוא score function שלא מתפרק באיזושהי צורה, אבל עקרונית זה פשוט מודל לא גלינארי.
ובדיוק כמו אתה שיקול של אותה גזירה שעשינו לפני שני שיעורים,
אתם יכולים לקבל בקלות שמה שיוצאת, הנגזרת החלקית הכי כן ביחס לפיצ'ר הכי של הלוג Likely ועוד.
זה פשוט הפיצ'ר Function. כן הפיצ'ר function במקום ה k של התשובה הנכונה.
כן, כלומר כשמציבים בפיצ'ר function את את הלייבלים הנכונים עבור המעבר.
What Super script I have מנוסחת תשובה script i פחות התוחלת של אותו הפיצ'ר כן, התוחלת של אותו הפיצ'ר כאשר מסוכמים על פני כל האפשרויות.
כן, בעצם. כן, בעצם מה שיוצא זה סכום על פני כל האפשרויות.
כן, כל הסדרות באורך i של t כפול ההסתברות שהמודל נותנים אותו וקטור משקולות לאותו y כפול הפיצ'ר הנכון כשבמקרה כאן מהו הפיצ'ר הנכון?
הפיצ'ר הנכון הוא בעצם סכום של כל הפיצ'רים של המעברים.
כן, כי בעצם אפשר לראות את זה שוב.
מי שלא משתכנע מה נפנופי ידיים שלי יכול בקלות לגזור את זה באותה דרך כמו שעשינו לפני שני שיעורים.
אבל תשימו לב שדרך שקולה לכתוב את Cars כן, דרך שקולה לכתוב את Cars זה איך זה בעצם נלך.
אפילו הלייקים אפשר להסתכל כאן, כן.
אז דרך שקולה לכתוב את Crash. כן ההסתברות של וואי סימנתם איקס, כלומר סדרה כזו כתבתי על זה.
וקטורים זה אמרנו, מוגדר להיות מכפלה של היא בחזקת אפס.
ג'יי. וואי וואי מינוס אחד.
Its full דאבליו. אחד הם.
חלקי זה של עץ כן חלקי הסכום על פני כל השרשרת.
דרך אחרת לכתוב יוצא שזה אולי ייראה לכם ממש דומה ללובלין יעמוד על זה שהכרתם.
כן, זה להכניס את המכפלה הזאת לתוך האקספוננט.
כן ואז בעצם זה E בחזקת מאה סכום נכון.
סכום על רגע I הייתי צריך טעות.
אין סכום א. ג'י שווה 1 אז אין את ג'י.
וואי וואי אחד את.
לכתוב נגד קנדה ולהיות אדם שונה.
כן כן. ואז אם תחשבו על זה, בעצם מה יש לנו כאן?
יש לנו מודה לא גלינארי, פשוט קצת. הדבר היחידי המשונה בו ביחס לסתם מודל לא בלי נערים.
עשרה לייבלים שראינו לפני שני שיעורים זה המודל הזה.
יש פשוט המון לייבלים וכמות הלייבלים למסה תלויה באורך הסדרה.
אבל עבור איזושהי תרומה ספציפית, מה שאנחנו לוקחים סדרה נכון, אנחנו לוקחים בעצם סדרה שזה לייבל מתוך מרחב הלייבלים.
אנחנו מחשבים לא את הפיצ'רים פרזנטי הישן שאנחנו מניחים כאן, שמתפרקת כסכום של פיצ'רים פרזנטי הישן זל.
מעברים סמוכים בסדר, אבל בגדול אפשר לחשוב על זה על כל הסכום הזה, פשוט כי feature function של כל השרשרת כולה.
נכון כל הדבר הזה, כל הדבר הזה זה פשוט פיצ'ר.
פעם כן. כן חומצות חוליות.
של כל השרשרת. לוקחים את התכניות, מכפילים אותם בווקטור משקולות, מקבלים סקלר נכון, מקבלים איזשהו סקור,
מעלים אותו ב האקספוננט, עושים את זה לכל הלייבלים, מחלקים בסכום של מה שקיבלנו.
זה בדיוק לובלין, עיר מודל נכון, רק בדרך כלל הכרנו אותו עם פחות משקולות ובלי צורה מיוחדת לפיצ'ר Function, אלא אמרנו סליחה.
ובלי צורה מיוחדת. לפיד פעם כשר אמרנו לא תעשו מה שאתם רוצים.
אז כאן יש צורה מיוחדת. היא חייבת להתפרק על דברים לא קלים.
יש צורה מיוחדת לפונקציית התכונית, אבל חוץ מזה זה פשוט.
זה פשוט לא בלי נייר מוזהב, זה כלום על הנייר. מודל. כשאתם עושים את החישוב מה שאתם מקבלים זה הגרדיאנט.
הוא פשוט הפיצ'ר Function הנכון.
כן, כלומר פיצ'ר function עבור אשכול solution.
כן עבור הכל Standard labs זה מה שכתוב לכם כאן פחות.
הפיצ'ר function בעצם התוחלת שלו כשאני ממשקל כל פיצ'ר, כל כל אפשרות לפי הספרות שהמודל נותן.
נכון אתם זוכרים את הנקודה קצת כן? אז מה למשל קורה?
אם כבר, המודל שלי הוא כזה שנותן לו Y.
יהיה נכון הסתברות דה פאקטו אחד על כמעט אחד.
אין מה לעשות זה לא נעשה נכון לא לזוז כי הסכום הזה נגיד נגיד בוא נסתכל על הגרסה השטוחה סטייט.
אוקיי, סטטיסטיקה. הייתי אינטרסנט, אז אין לנו סכימה על פני כל האינסטנט C.
אז אם עבור Instant מסוים וואלאס W שהגעתי אליו כבר נותן לי את הפתרון הנכון, לא נעשה כמעט שום עדכון כרגע.
נכון? כי התוחלת של הפיצ'ר function שווה לפיצ'ר function הנכון, אבל אם הם מאוד רחוקים אז איכשהו נצטרך לקחת את ההפרש ביניהם.
כן נגיד למשל הוא שם את כל המסך על פשוט Y אחר על סדרה אחרת אין בעיה.
מחשבים את הפיצ'ר function שזה נכון. מחשבים את הפיצ'ר function של הדבר שאדם שלנו חושב שהוא נכון בטעות כן ועושים ביניהם חיסון וזה בעצם צעד.
היתרון בסדר, אז זה בדיוק אותו מקרה. כמובן שאז, אם זה כל כך אותו מקרה, מה בעצם הסיפור?
מה הבעיה? למה לא אמרתי לכם? טוב, זה לא גלי ניר מודל אז תעשו מה שעושים אם לא בלי נקודת.
מה דעתכם על הביטוי הזה לגרדיאן? המוזרות החוקית?
קשה לחשב נכון למה קשה לחשב אותו. על כל הדוגמאות בדיוק אנחנו אומרים אפילו בוא נעזוב שניה את זה.
כן, זה עברנו על כל הדוגמאות. זה תמיד אנחנו רגילים, מגרדים בסנדוויץ, סטוקס מגרדים את זה, לא מטריד אותם.
הבעיה היא זאת נכון. הבעיה היא שעבור כל אינסטנט אנחנו צריכים ללכת ולעבור על פני כל מרחב הסיכון האפשריים.
לכל אחד מהם לחשב את ההסתברות לחשב את הפיצ'ר Function, כלומר כסכום של פיצ'ר function זה למעברים ולנהל את זה.
כן לחשב את זה לא ילך לפחות לבבות פורסט.
מה אפשר אז בכל זאת לעשות תכנון דינמי בעצם?
אבל איך? איך? איך עושים את הדבר הזה עם תכנון דינמי? זה מה שאנחנו נראה עכשיו.
שאלות לפני שניצור פרטים. אוקיי, יפה.
אז אנחנו רוצים לעשות תכנון דינמי. איך אנחנו עושים את זה?
אז אנחנו דבר ראשון צריכים טיפה לארגן את הסכימה הזאת אחרת.
אז אוקיי, כפי שאמרנו, הגורם הבעייתי עבורנו זה הגורם.
לגורם השני כן, הגורם הראשון זה פשוט להציב. כן.
אז אני העתקתי כאן את הגורם השני. כן את הגורם השני.
על מה הנגזרת החלקית כן או מה עקבותיהן.
זה גם בצורה וקטורי ובוא טיפה נארגן אותו מחדש.
אז במקום לסחור על פני כל האפשרויות על פני כל הסדרות, בואו נוציא החוצה דווקא את בוא נוציא החוצה את המעברים.
כן, סכימה בעצם את סכימה על ג'רי הסכימה למעברים, ומה שאנחנו נשים לב זה שבגלל שהצורה המיוחדת של הפיצ'ר function של הפיצ'ר function שהוא בעצם רגיש,
לא לכל הסדרה אלא כל פעם רק לזוג יכול כל פעם רק לזוג עוקב של האיגלס.
אז בעצם יוצא שאנחנו מחשבים את אותו דבר הרבה פעמים כן, כי בעצם עבור כל סדרה של Y שבה וואי ג'יי שווה.
וואי וואי חמש שווה לa. וואי ארבע שווה לפי.
אנחנו צריכים לחשב את הפיצ'ר Function הזה נכון?
ולמה לנו לעשות את זה? בוא נעשה את זה פעם אחת. כן ואז בעצם מה שאנחנו אומרים זה בסדר.
בוא נוציא החוצה. בעצם נחליף את סדר הסימן, נוציא החוצה את המעברים.
זה תמיד אפשר לעשות כן. אז אנחנו עכשיו חכמים על ג'יי ואז מסתכלים על Y.
אבל אז כמו שאמרנו שבגלל של Ask הוא מתוך כל הוואי הכביר הזה הוא בעצם תלוי רק בזוג עבור ג'יי קבוע.
כן, 5 מעבר מספר 5 הוא תלוי רק במה שכתוב בסדרה הזאת במקום 5 ומה שכתוב לה במקום.
4. נכון. אז אין בעיה. אז אם ככה, בוא נזרום על פני כל האפשרויות.
למה יכול להיות Y חמש? ומה יכול להיות Y?
4. בסדר לכל אחד מהם. מה שאנחנו נעשה זה נחשב את הדבר הזה בדיוק באותו אופן.
אוקיי. ואז השאלה מה קורה לגורם הזה?
כן, הגורם הזה בעצם נכון הוא המכפלה.
מי כל המעברים? אוקיי, אז יש לנו פה את הגורם הזה.
הגורם הזה הוא משותף לכל המוסכמים פה. נכון הגורם הזה.
ברגע שקבענו את ג'יי וברגע שקבענו את וואי וואי גיים מינוס אחד.
הדבר הזה הוא פשוט קבוע. כן לא קבוע ומה שנשאר לנו כאן זה בעצם המרת פה בבלתי כן,
בעצם ההסתברות השולית לקבל את Y ג'יי מינוס את וואי ג'יי שווה ל הוואי, כי הספציפי שבחרתי a ו y כי אין מינוס אחד שווה B יפה.
אז הסכימה הזאת היא סכימה ליניארית. זה בסדר, סכימה הזאתי ריבועית במספר Label זה עדיין נראה בסדר.
זה פשוט להציב בפיצ'ר Function. גם זה נראה בסדר, אבל האיבר התמים הזה דורש עוד קצת עבודה, נכון?
כי בעצם מאיפה אני יודע בכלל מה ההסתברות השולית כן לקבל?
מה? שום דבר בנוסחת craft הוא אומר לי איך לקבל את ההסתברות השולית של של וואי 5 שווה?
כן? מה ההסתברות שהשרשרת שלי היא אחת השרשראות שבה הוואי חמש שווה a וy ארבע שווה b.
נכון, זה בעצם השאלה ההסתברות השולית נכון? מה?
מה הסיכוי שאם אני הגריל Y לפי ההתפלגות שאושרה על ידי דבליו על פני השרשראות האפשריות, אני דווקא אקבל במקום הרביעי B ובמקום החמישי A.
נכון, זה בעצם השאלה שעומדת מולי, והנוסחה הזאת לא אומרת לי בדיוק את זה נכון?
היא אומרת לי אם תיתן לי את כל הסדרה לa a, B, c, d וכן הלאה, אז אני אגיד לך בסדר, תחשב את האקספוננט הזה וכן תכפיל ותן הרמל בסוף.
אבל לכן אני מקבל התפלגות שולית. אז אוקי, אז שאלה מעניינת.
זו בעצם השאלה שנחה לפתחנו, ומסתבר שאפשר לפתור את זה באמצעות תכנון דינמי באמצעות אלגוריתם שנקרא forward background שאולי חלקכם שמעתם עליו.
מי שלומד על HTML זה מאוד דומה לגרסה שעושה את שניהם, אבל אני יודע שרובכם נתקלו בזה בקורסים אחרים אז אני פשוט אלמד את זה מהתחלה.
אז מה המטרה שלנו? המטרה שלנו היא למצוא את ההסתברות השולית כאן.
פשוט חזרתי על זה כאן. בהינתן שקבענו איזשהו,
אנחנו עכשיו הולכים לקבוע איזה שהוא a ואיזשהו B נכון ולהגיד אני עכשיו רוצה לדעת מה
ההסתברות שאם אני אקרא לשרשרת ההתפלגות היא תהיה שרשרת כזאת שבה וואי ג'יי Oh what מנוסחת?
אוקיי, נכון, זה השאלה שמעניינת אותנו. זה המקדם של הדבר הזה שקולה לסכום על פני כל השרשראות.
כן, כל השרשראות שבהם וואי ג'יי שווה מינוס אחד שווה B אז ההסתברות לאותה שרשרת ספציפית נכון.
אם אני אתחיל לעבור שבכל השרשראות נגיד זה ההסתברות שלה היא ככה.
ההסתברות של זאתי ככה סכום על פני כל הקומבינציות. בסוף אני אקבל את ההסתברות של הקבוצה.
כן, זה ברור, זה פשוט הגדרה של הסתברות שולית של מה שרק הסביר שם.
אז איך אנחנו נעשה את זה? אז בסדר, הדרך תהיה דרך הבא.
דבר ראשון אנחנו עוד נכניס טיפה מוטציות, נוציא אחת.
זה המעבר הבין Y לוואי היטב במקום ה i.
כן, זה בעצם הדבר שבשיא הרצף מחליף את הסתברויות המעבר.
כי נכון אם היה לנו הסתברות מעבר במקרה של כן במקרה של אמ.
נכון בסי הרי זה כבר לא הסתברויות מעבר זה פקטורי מעבר נכון לא נורמלי.
כלומר האקספוננט של הפיצ'ר Function.
אם מציבים באיי הוואי הייתה y ו x כן והם עושים מכפלה סקלרית עם טבלת בסדר אז זה פשוט ניקוד המעבר או איך שתקראו לזה.
בסדר, זה כבר לא הסתברות, אבל זה איזשהו מספר חיובי שנובע מהפיד של Function.
ואיזה אינדקס אתם עכשיו בסדרה ובין איזה תגיות אתם עוברים?
ועכשיו אני יכול להגדיר את אלפא ואת בטא? אוקיי, אז באמת, האם סכומים חלקיים הם בעצם תתי בעיות?
כן או בעיות יותר פשוטות באיזשהו מובן שמהם בתכנון דינמי אני אבנה את הפתרון.
בעיה כללית. אז א ה של Y הוא שווה לסכום על פני כל השרשראות שמסתיימות ב ע מינוס 1.
אוקיי. בלייבל הזה בלייבל Y בסדר.
אז ה Y זה לסחוב על פי כל השרשראות או כל הרשתות של שרשראות בסדר שהם באורך i מינוס אחד ומסתיימות בוואי, כלומר סכום על פני כל השרשראות האלה של מכפלה.
על כן שווה לאחד את i שווה לכן אחד עד i מינוס אחד של פקטור של פקטור המעבר mk week מינוס אחד Y.
כן, בסדר, זה הגדרה כרגע פשוט אני סוחב על פני כל הרשתות.
כנל יש לי את בטא. בטא הוא מאוד דומה רק שעובד הפוך.
הוא מסתכל על צפיפות. בסדר, הוא מסתכל על מסלולים.
כן, על בעצם על על שיפוט של מסלולים.
בסדר שמתחילים במקום i ונגמרים בסוף bn ומתחילים באיזה שהוא y ספציפי.
אז בית ה y הוא הסכום על פני כל הסיפור של שרשראות שמתחילות באינדקס ה i עם הלייבל Y ונגמרות איפשהו בוואי בסדר נגמרות איפשהו בסוף הסידרה.
יפה עכשיו מה שנחמד זה שאם היה לי את אותם אלפא ובטא, תשימו לב שמצבי היה ממש טוב.
למה? כי בוא נסתכל. בוא נגיד שאתם עכשיו רוצים באמת לחשב את אותו i y.
הייתם בסדר? נגיד שאתם רוצים לחשב את my אפס.
סליחה, אתם רוצים לחשב את ההסתברות של כן איזשהו וואי ג'יי 9 מינוס אחד עבור איזשהו ג'יי נתון ועבור ערכים מסוימים A וb לווי קיבל y מינוס אחד.
אז מה שאתם אומרים זה בעצם את הדבר הבא אני יכול לחשוב על זה, נגיד שוב את לשקף כן ולהגיד בסדר,
אני יודע שאני אם אני כבר קבעתי שבה אינדקס הג'י, נגיד באינדקס הרביעי אני עובר בין הלייבל אל הרבי לאין.
אין זה אומר שהמסלול שלי חייב לעבור דרך הצלע הזאת.
נכון, כל מסלול שעובר דרך הצלע הזאת בהכרח עובר בין אן בין אל על פי לאן אן באינדקס הרביעי וההפך.
כן, כל מה שעובר בין אל הרבי באינדקס הרביעי עובר דרך הצלע הזאת.
כלומר דרך שקולה לחשוב על בעיית מציאת המון שינה, על זה סכימה על פני כל המסלולים שעוברים דרך צלע נתונה.
בתכלס קבעתי צלע, עכשיו אני שוכב על פני כל המסלולים.
נכון? עכשיו אם יש לי את אותם אלפא ובטא כן.
אם יש לי את אותם אלפא ובטא, מה אני יכול לעשות? אני יכול להגיד בסדר, אני עכשיו רוצה.
כן, כאן הסתכלתי על הצלע הזאת, לא משנה שלוש NN לארבע אל הרבי.
אז בעצם אני יכול לקחת את סכום כל המסלולים מההתחלה שנגמרים בקודקוד, בקודקוד שממנו אני יוצא בצלע.
כן, בעצם בקודקוד, בשכבה ה מינוס.
אחד שהלייזר שלו הוא בנוסחת שקבעתי ואני יכול להסתכל על זה פשוט אלפא.
מה זה כאן? אלפא שלוש n ואני יכול להסתכל על בית ארבע.
זה יהיה אלפא ארבע n כי האינדקס שם הוא סט באחד לא משנה.
זה עניין האינטרקציה ואני יכול להסתכל על בטא ארבע של אל הרבי.
זה יתן יצרו כל המסלולים שיוצאים מהקודקוד הזה וממשיכים באיזושהי צורה עד הסוף.
ועכשיו אם אני שיכפול עץ הסכימה של כל מה שמגיע עד תחילת הצלע הזאת, כן, ואת כל מה שמגיע מהסוף עד סוף הצלע הזאת אני אקבל.
כן. איך זה נקרא חוק הפילוג? נכון, אני אקבל את כל הקומבינציות של ריש התווספות של הצלע.
אז עכשיו אם אני אלך והכפיל את הבטטות, את הבטא המתאימה באלפא המתאים, כן,
את הסכום מההתחלה עד הצלע של אז הצלע המדוברת והסכום מייצג סוף הצלע המדוברת עד הסוף, ואני נכפיל אותם בסכום של המעבר הספציפי שאני רוצה.
כן, זה הצלע המשותפת לכולם. כן, זה היה בדיוק אזכור של הצלע המשותפת לכולם,
הצלע שעוברת בין ג'יימס אחד לג'יי ושכבה ב ג'יי מנצחת ג'יי דרך הלייבלים וואי וואי ג'יי מיילס אחד הספציפים שקבעתי.
אז אני אקבל בדיוק את הסכום של כל המכפלות בסדרה, כל המסלולים שעוברים דרך הצלע.
זה ברור לחזור על זה עוד פעם. אם אם מישהו כאן רוצה לבוא אליי בהפסקה, לשאול אותי על זה כי זה לא ברור, אז עדיף לשאול עכשיו.
כן, מחזור כן. תודה. בסדר, אז נעשה את זה ואז זה יהיה ואז נצא להפסקה.
אז בעצם מה שאנחנו אומרים זה את הדבר הבא. אנחנו רוצים להסתכל על כל המסלולים שנגיד עוברים דרך הצלע.
זאת. בסדר. זה בדיוק אמרתי פה וביליתי שההסתברות ש וואי ארבע שווה אל ערבי.
וואי שלוש שווה n. נכון זה בדיוק ההסתברות השולית.
ככה היא מוגדרת ההסתברות השולית, כי מהי ההסתברות לקבל את הצלע הזאת?
אני לא יודע איך לתת הסתברויות שוליות לשיא הרצף. אומר לי רק לתת.
איך נותנים הסתברויות מלאות על שרשרת. אבל אם אני אלך ולסחוב על פני כל השרשראות המלאות שעוברות דרך הצלע הזאת ועל ההסתברויות שלהם,
שזה פשוט מכפלת הצלעות שמרכיבות אותם, אז אני אקבל את ההסתברות לעבור דרך הצלע נכון שתשוחרר לפני כל תתי מאורעות האפשרים.
יפה עכשיו איך אני מקבל את? איך אני מקבל את ההסתברות לעבור דרך הצלע הזאת?
אז אני מקבל אותה על ידי סכימת כל המסלולים שעוברים דרך הצלע הזאת. איך אני מקבל את הסכום על פני כל המסלולים שעוברים דרך הצלע הזאת?
מה? אז כל סכום כזה מורכב מ איזשהו מסלול איזושהי רישא של מסלול?
כן, משהו שמגיע מההתחלה עד הקודקוד הזה, ומשהו שמגיע מהקודקוד הזה עד הסוף.
בסדר. אז עכשיו, אם יהיה לי את סכום כל המסלולים שמגיעים עד כאן ואת סכום כל המסלולים מכאן שמגיעים עד הסוף מכאן, סליחה שמגיעים עד הסוף.
אוקיי, אני יכפיל את הסכום הזה, את הבטא ואת הסכום הזה, את האלפא.
אז בוא נראה. אז בעצם מה יש לנו? יהיה לנו איזשהו אלפא?
נכון, יהיה לנו איזשהו אלפא שהוא סכום של של ההסתברות, של מסלול אחד.
לא משנה. בוא נקרא לו כן וואי.
ואני נותן בהסתברות של מסלול.
כן זה 12. כמה זה יהיה בסכום של הרבה הרבה רכישות של מסלולים.
נכון שמגיעים שמגיעים עד הקודקוד הזה.
M. כן. ומה בטח יהיה קונספטואלית, בטח שמתאים.
הוא יהיה סכום תקני שיפוט של מסלולים. יכול להיות שמתחילים פה ומגיעים עד הסוף?
כן. אז גם פה יש איזשהו מסלול הליכה.
על מסלולי. בסדר.
ועכשיו מה יקרה כשאני הכפיל את אלפא ובטא? מה שאני אקבל זה בדיוק.
כן, אני פותח סוגריים. מה שאני מקבל זה בדיוק את הסכום של כל הקומבינציות של מכפלה מכאן, במכפלה מכאן, נכון.
ואם אני כופה את כל את אלפא כפול בטא כפול המשקל של הצלע הזאת, אז מה שאני אקבל זה בדיוק סכום משקלי כל המסלולים מהתחלה עד הסוף שעוברים דרך הצלע הזאת.
פשוט הכפלתי את זה בחלקים. אוקיי, קודם הכפלתי את הרישא.
עד שלוש שנים אחרי זה הכפלתי את הסיפא, את המשקל של הסיפא מארבע אל הרבי, ואחרי זה הכפלתי את הצלע ביניהם.
לא משנה, אבל זה אותו דבר. בסדר, אז אחרי ההפסקה נסיים את זה ונעבור לנושא הבא.
בוא נחזור שלוש דקות אחרי שסיימנו. איך אתה מציג אותה בכלל?
יש שם עוד כמה כתבות שם ברשת. אה?
שוב שכחתי להעלות את המעמ נכון? אה סליחה כן, אני אעלה עכשיו.
לשים לעצמי תזכורת כזאת. כן דיברתי.
אני רוצה. ברפואה סינית.
אבל זה בגלל. את.
זה בדיוק מה. אין.
אבל על הזמן. למזלה של.
זוכרים? כל אפשרות שהם לא עושים.
אם. לא.
אני. בצורה זכתה.
אין שכל. הגברים מתגייסים זה עובר אחד לשני.
אבל צריך לדעת. אני אגיד לך שכל החיילים סביבך צריכים לעשות עבודה קשה.
סכסוך. איפה אתה יושב ראש החברה לשעבר?
זה לא היה מזמן. בוא נגיד שקיבלתי רק שבוע.
הדבר שהכי אהבתי את הטיפוס המוזר הזה. מה זאת אומרת אין טעם לשבור את הקרח עם סחורה אחרת?
אני רוצה לשחק את המשחק כי אז יש לי את האופי. יש לי גם אני בהנדסה, אז אני עושה רק מה שחסר לי.
משהו שבני הנוער. כן יש בו משהו מדעי הרוח.
נכון, ראיתי משהו כן, אבל לא לקחתי אחד. חיפשתי משהו שיעשה.
זה בדיוק היום כאילו יש לי שעה שעתיים הרצאה שעה.
איזה בוס רוצה לומר לי? 35 מיליארד דולר מדי שנה?
רוב הסיכויים שלא לדבר על הנושא. אני כל כך עד היום לא מצליח, אבל זה ממשיך להעסיק אותנו.
הכוונה שלנו. רצינו להיות שזה רעיון.
כבר שלושה עשורים ואני מנסה לחזור בתשובה, לעשות שני דברים שיותר מתחברים.
ביולוגיה. כאשר הצד.
אתה לוקח על עצמי להוביל תכנית.
אז זהו זה. זה גן ילדים. על המציאה.
כביכול הייתי יכול גם לקחת דברים שבהדסה היה לי, אבל התוצאה.
וזה מעצבן כי שנכנסתי. זה היה העז.
כמו כן, בקבוצה מבשלים וטועמים במיוחד.
אומנם פיתוח זה אמור להיות צבעוני בתחילת.
אבל כמו שאני כבר שנים לפני כן, נכון?
של דבר. אבל השאלה הראשונה שלך שופטת.
עברתי על בשרי במשך. שלוש שעות.
הסיטואציה הזאת יוצרת איזה.
בסך הכל שתי החברות בקבוצה של ביבי.
אתה חושב שכבר דיברתי?
אנחנו איתך! פשוט עד הסוף. יכול להיות של אמצעי מניעה, אבל אני כן יודעת להגיד לך, אבל לגבי הסימסטר קודם.
ומי המפסיד? כל גבר רוצה להיות שם.
עכשיו בואו נזכיר שאמרתי את השם של הבחורה.
עד היום זה לא שהגענו. איך הגענו?
אנחנו לקחנו את. אני כל הזמן בתעלה, אבל נדמה לי שכן שיש לך בארץ הקודש מלמעלה למטה.
אז יש יותר עשייה משנה לשנה שאני.
ויש. מה אתה רוצה לעשות מבחינת?
כן הפיצה נראתה לי. יש לי דלקת אוזניים.
שלום לכולכם. יש פה מלא יש פה.
למעלה מ 25 שנה עכשיו.
אני לא יכולה לשבת בשקט בימי גשם שניים.
יש בה להמיס את הלב. ביום שני מעבירים את הקורס שלב מתקדם.
אני לא זוכרת את הפעם. אני חושב שזה יצא מוזר לי שאתה מצליח עכשיו.
אני בסמסטר האחרון לתואר הזה ואם הייתי רוצה לא היה מתאפשר.
שלום, אני אישה מלאכותית. אני ממליצה לך לעשות את זה בשנה הראשונה, השנה השנייה, כך עשיתי.
אני אישית לוקח כאילו יצא משהו מסריח בדרך שמזכירה לי.
יש לנו עוד חברים לספר לכם שצריכים לעשות את הדבר הנכון כדי לקבל את ההחלטה להגיע.
את הכביסה אנחנו עושים בארץ, לא? זאת הייתה שנה שעבדתי.
אני חושב שאנחנו אנשי הביצוע של.
גם בשנה שעברה יש פה גם זה.
הוא היה. יש פה בעיה יוסי.
אה, וככה זה גם ממש מעניין. הביקורת שלך לא תשנה כלום.
אשכח? מה זה אומר שאני כבר עושה את זה במקרי אונס?
פשוט כאילו. לדעתי אתה רוצה לא להגיע ליותר.
אני חושבת שאם הייתה לי בחילה כאילו כל הסקס, השקט.
והשלווה היה ברור יותר ממה שהיא אמרה שלקח.
אני רוצה להיות מסוגלת לקחת את הבוס שלי דאז ועושה מה שבא לי.
אין מה לעשות. במהלך התואר אפשר הספיקה.
כבר יותר מעשר שנים. שהגיע אתמול למחנה האימונים של רמת השרון שלנו על ידי ג'ון טרי טרי, שכבר עשה, היה בוושינגטון באופן הזה בסמסטר הזה של 2010.
אצטרך שתעזרו. לי להשיג.
איזה אדם. ואז הוא יהיה בתרדמת.
כן, אני צריכה טיפול רפואי.
אני עשיתי לייזר זה. מה אני אגיד לך?
מה זה את? אז היום זה כל מה שצריך, אבל זה מאוד.
לא? יעזור.
עסק כזה באופן קבוע צריך להכין סמסטר ויותר מזה צריך להשקיע.
חשוב להשקיע בכל התחומים מספר שעות העבודה, הסיפוק והתחושה לעשות את.
בחצי השנה הראשונה של השנייה המדהימה.
טוב פתחת את התוכנית הזאת.
יאללה שיהיה לך בכיף. אני מעשן 25 בדצמבר 2004.
שלושה חד פעמי של הסיפור הזה. לא?
כדי להגיע לשלב הזה אתם חייבים.
אז זהו זה גם השנה הרביעית שלך אתה כבר בטח בשנה הרביעית, אבל עדיין את מה שרצית.
מה אני צריכה אותם? זה אני הצעתי לבקר בבית.
11.
היא הייתה טובה במיוחד. את.
לך. זה היה את יותר.
אחד אחר. של ביתר.
ירושלים. אף אחד לא צריך להיות נוכח.
אחרי כמה שנים שבהן היה ילד אחד.
יוסי מצא. מאות אלפי אנשים עשו את זה, אבל.
טוב נמשיך. אז אוקיי, אז אנחנו מקווה שהשתכנעו שאם היה לנו את אותה אליפות ובטטות אז סך הכל המצב היה טוב דרמטית.
מכיוון שהיינו יכולים לכתוב את המרשם על דיסק ישן של KYD מינוס אחד פשוט כמכפלה על האליפות והבטטות הרלוונטיות כפולה Score של הצלע שחייבים לעבור בה,
וזה בעצם היה משאיר רק גורם אחד עלום שהוא זה כן המכנה.
אבל בעצם גם הוא היינו יכולים להסתדר איתו אם היה לנו את האליפות והבטטות.
איך למשל? מה זה?
זה בעצם ספירת זרע? האם זה בדיוק זה בעצם?
או במושגים של הטרולי סכום על כל המסלולים? נכון?
לא אלה שעוברים דרך צלע מסויימת זה ממש הסכום של כולם.
אז מה דעתכם? מה דעתכם? כי זה בדיוק מה שאתה מנסה לפענח.
נחשב נכון, אבל אם היו לי את הבת שלי מה זה אלפא אלפא?
זה בעצם סכימה על הכל מההתחלה עד קודקוד נתון גרף הבטא האחרון פשוט נכון?
או אם יש לי כאן מעלפות כי יש כמה אפשרויות לתא האחרון או לסכום אותם נכון vin בטא.
אם היה לי רק את בטא גם הייתי מסתדר אז אתה נשאר נכון?
כן, הייתי לוקח בטא של אפס S.
נכון, זה היה כן, זה היה הכל. אז בעצם מה היה קורה?
כמה באמת קילומטר ראשון? בטא הוא תמיד מאיפה שאתה מתחיל אותו עד הסוף.
זה פשוט צריך להגיע גם מהסוף להתחלה.
זה כמו הערכת מצב בסוף. באיזה מובן זה סימטרי, כלומר זה זהה.
האלפא האחרון הוא זהה לבטא, הראשון ממש אבל כן, אבל באמצע זה אחר כן.
נכון? או דרך שלישית לעשות כן? אם אתם ממש מחפשים דרכים שונות זה תזכרו שבעצם הדבר הזה הוא כבר כן התפלגות נכון.
אז אם אני אסכם אם אני בעצם יש לי גורם נרמול נכון, אז דרך שקולה לחשב אותו.
אז אם יש לי את המונים נכון ויש לנו כולם אותו מכנה.
אז איך אני מוצא את המכנה לסחור בסכום על כל האפשרויות השונות ל Y מינוס אחד על המונים שאני מקבל?
אוקיי, אז בכל מקרה לא צריך לדאוג והמכנה כי הוא קבוע.
נכון, הוא קבוע עבור כל הערכים של Y. גיבוי אחד אפשר להתגבר עליו בסדר ועכשיו נשאר.
אז רק השאלה איך מחשבים את האלף כותבי הבית. אבל בעצם גם זה לא מסובך, כי זה מאוד דומה לביטוי.
כן? והנה נוסחת הנסיגה. אוקיי, טוב, ברור שאלפא של הקודקוד הראשון זה טריוויאלית, פשוט נגיד אם זה ממש קודקוד לקודקוד.
ממש כן אפס אפס. אז מה זה סכום כל המסלולים שזה כן משהו כזה.
אז כן, אז כאילו זה מן המקרה המנוון. בגלל שאנחנו אחרי זה נרצה להכפיל כל פעם את אלפא.
זה אנחנו לא נרצה לקבוע אותו כאפס. בעצם זה יוצא אחד.
אבל גם אם אתם נראה לכם קצת לא אינטואיטיבי, אז גם אלפא שהשכבה הראשונה.
מה זה נגיד אלפא של זה של הקודקוד הזה? בסדר, זה בדיוק זה.
משקל הצלע מאפס אלפא בטא של הקודקוד.
נגיד הזה זה גם פשוט סכום על פני כל הצלעות שנכנסות אלפא.
זאת אומרת, אוקיי, נקרא הקצה הם פשוטים וגם לעבור מאיי מינוס אחד לאיי באלפא זה גם די פשוט.
כן, כי מה הוא סך הכל סכום כל המסלולים שמגיעים נגיד עד לפה.
אז אם יש לי את הסכום של כל מה שמגיע עד פה, כל מה שמגיע לפה, כל מה שמגיע עד פה, כל מה שמגיע עד פה וכל מה שמגיע עד פה.
אז אני פשוט אקח את כל מה שמגיע עד פה. נכפיל אותם בצלע הזאת.
כל מה שמגיע פה מכל צלע הזאת, כל אחת מגיע פה, נכפול בצלע הזאת וכן הלאה.
ואז הסכום. את כל מה שאני מקבל מקבל פשוט את כל המסלולים שמגיעים עד פה.
נכון, כי הם חייבים לעבור דרך איזה שהיא דרישה מאחד הקודקודים של השכבה הקודמת.
אז קל לחשב את אלפא i בהינתן אלפא i מינוס 1 מה לגבי את בית האיי מינוס אחד?
בהינתן בית ה i, גם זה לא אותו דבר, נכון?
אז אם אני רוצה את הבית, כלומר את סכום כל השאיפות שמתחילות מכאן,
אז אני יכול לקחת את סכום כל השאיפות שמתחילות מכאן, סכום על השאיפות שמתחילות מכאן מכאן מכאן תבדקו את זה.
אני עכשיו רוצה לעשות את זה. אני רוצה לעשות את זה, אני רוצה לעשות וכן הלאה, ואני אקבל את סכום כל השאיפות שמתחילות מכאן.
אז גם זה די פשוט. אפילו באיזשהו מובן.
יותר פשוט מפיטר בי לא צריך בק רויטרס לשום דבר כזה.
זה נוסחת נסיגה מאוד פשוטה. אלפא איי וואי זה בעצם אפשר אפילו לכתוב את זה בכתיבה.
המטרה הציונית כזאת נכון. כן, זה בעצם פשוט הווקטור אלפא של השכבה הקודמת כפול המעברים הרלוונטים ובטא זה פשוט הציר של השכבה הבאה כפולה ב הרלוונטית.
אז אוקיי, אז זה מצוין וזה XT כמו שאמרנו זאת גם לא בעיה.
אם כבר יש לי טלפון ובטטות ואפילו אפשר להסתדר אם אין לי אותם ואם רפרנס, זה בדיוק מה שאמרנו קודם.
בדיוק אותו רעיון של פיטר באק, כמו בימיהם, הם בעצם אנלוגי לגמרי.
חוץ מזה שהחישוב של מספרי הצלעות טיפה משתנים.
טוב, אז זה crash קצת ככה בשביל להבין בערך איפה אנחנו עומדים מבחינת פה.
אז מספיק שתגיד שזאת הייתה בעיה ככה שהשתמשנו בה כדוגמה רצה.
אז בגדול אלה תוצאות עבור המקרה הכימי שהכי נחקר בזמנו, שעבדו יחסית הרבה שהוא מקרה של אנגלית עם דומיין ספציפית.
זה היה חדשות. כן, שהתעסקו בו אז סופר ויי Setting in דומיין.
כלומר זה היה, והאתרים נלקחים מאותה התפלגות.
מה שהייתם מקבלים זה פחות או יותר את הדבר הבא המוסקט, ביטקוין tag פשוט.
אם הייתי יודע לגבי כל. מה התג הנפוץ ביותר עבורה.
כלומר, הייתי מתעלם מזה שהמילים האלה מופיעות בשרשרת באיזשהו הקשר, פשוט בהינתן שהייתי יודע מה הוא, הייתי מתייג כל מילה בתג הסביר ביותר שלה.
נגיד את מין בתור נער ואת זה בתור וטרינר ולא יודע או כבר וטרינר וכן הלאה.
הייתי מקבל בערך 90 אחוז דיוק.
זה כמובן בהנחה שהייתי יודע מה. Most likely talks.
כן, גם בשביל זה צריך איזשהו דאטה או איזשהו מקור לקבל את זה ממנו.
על אנדרואיד זה כן משהו כמו היתר, כמו ארבעים וחמש אחוז.
בעצם זה גודל הקטגוריה הגדולה ביותר באותו סט קלאסי שהשתמשו בו, שזה בעצם היה קומן ארטס.
מסתבר שכל מיינר זה בערך 45 אחוז, כך שיש לתייג את כולם פשוט בקטגוריה הנפוצה ביותר, שזה הדבר הכי טוב שאפשר לעשות.
אם זה היה נכון, אם זה מילה שלא נתקלנו בה ואנחנו מתעלמים מהקונטקסט, זה משהו כזה מטריד, גרם HMD.
כן, אז היא כמה ימים נתנו בוסט משמעותי כי הם סגרו בערך חצי מהטעות.
כן, הורידו 50 אחוז מהטעות במילים ידועות, אבל בגדול ההכללה שלהם לאנדרואיד לא הייתה מדהימה בכלל.
אוקיי, וזה גם נובע מזה שכן דיברנו על זה ש הפיצ'רים שם הם מאוד מוגבלים.
נכון, יש לנו רק את mission ו condition. אנחנו בכלל לא לוקחים בחשבון את הצורה של המילה ולמרות כל שיטות ההחלקה,
סך הכל הביצועים על אנור וויץ, כלומר מילים שלא הופיעו בטריינינג Data לא הייתה משהו.
אז הייתה עבודה בשנת 2000 שהראתה כל מיני שיטות החלקה יותר מתוחכמות, יותר מותאמות בפרט speed.
סייגים קראו לזה tilt וכפי שאתם רואים זה העלה דרמטית את את השיעור, את השיעור, הדיוק בהן הוא מאוד כן, היה.
אוקיי, איזשהו זה בעצם לא בלי נייר מודל לוקאלי?
כן, אז זה כבר בעצם מודל דיסקים מנתיבי, אבל מודל מסחרי מנתיבי שלא מבצע פר דיקציה גלובלית כן,
לא מבצע של כל Wine בנפרד, אלא בית ספר דיגיטלי שכל מילה כבעיה כבעיה נפרדת קיבל סך הכל תוצאות דומות.
לכן MM גם הוא קיבל תוצאות מאוד דומות.
השיח F שיפר ב.
כן, זה אולי נראה לכם כמו הבדל מאוד דרמטי, אבל זה בהחלט הבדל.
זה גם עוד משהו שחשוב לי להגיד לכם מבחינת קריאה של תוצאות.
אומנם אתם יכולים לחשוב שאולי Cars אתם אומרים בסדר, אז הוא קיבל 90.
הוא עלה בערך בארבע בערך מחצי אחוז, נגיד פחות קצת מחצי אחוז והוא עלה.
באנו לארץ בערך ב2 נקודה 11 אחוז ואתם אומרים נו, לא נשמע כמו משהו ששווה להתעסק בו בכלל, אבל צריך לקחת בחשבון שזה מאוד תלוי בסטים.
כן? אז דבר ראשון העניין הזה שלנו בארץ הוא מאוד חשוב, כי בעצם באותו זמן NLP ואנחנו נדבר קצת בהמשך הקורס על ויועציה של NLP בימינו.
אבל, אבל יועץ השווה NLP באזור הזמן ההוא, נגיד עד לפני עד בעצם שהתחיל עניין אדיר מהתעשייה בנושא, היה בעיקר מבוסס על בנצ'מרק,
עם סטנדרטים ביחס לתקצוב שהיה לקהילה לפני שגוגל ואופן AI ומטה וכן הלאה, החליטו לשפוך על זה אינסוף כסף.
היה תקצוב הרבה יותר מתון וליועץ, כך שאי אפשר היה לתייג קורפוסים עצומים, בטח לא עבור שפות שונות מאנגלית, בטח לא עבור דומיינים יחסית לא נפוצים.
ובעצם מה שהייתם מקבלים זה א הרבה מאוד ובעצם בהרבה מאוד מקרים מעט מעט מאוד Data להתעסק בו, כך שאנו words היה דבר מאוד נפוץ.
כן, זאת אומרת מילים שלא הופיעו chain עם data היה דבר מאוד נפוץ, אז זה דבר אחד שצריך לקחת בחשבון בשני אחוז האלה.
אם אתם מסתכלים על האינטרנט, כלומר כמה בני אדם מסכימים, אוקיי, כי מעבר לזה, ההנחה היא שגם אי אפשר לשאול האם היא נכונה או לא.
אבל ההנחה היא שמעבר לאינטרנט איתו גרים, אין זה בעיקר רעש.
כן, רעש בתיוג אפשר לחלוק, אז זה נושא לשיעור אחר.
אז אם אתם מניחים שבעצם ממה לשני אחוז זה רעש.
אוקיי, ואתם עכשיו נמצאים ב 86 נקודה 9.
כלומר יש אתם 11 נקודה 11 אחוז מתחת. לכן לדרגת הרעש כאילו דרגה אופטימלית והצלחתם לסגור את זה בקצת יותר משני אחוז.
אז הורדתם איזה סדר גודל של 20 אחוז מהטעות כנראה על המקרה יותר מעניין.
א הוא יותר מעניין בגלל שהתראיין נגדי. בהרבה מקרים הוא מוגבל ובטעות צריך לקחת בחשבון שבעצם אם אתם מסתכלים על התוצאות האלה,
אתם כבר מבינים שבעצם אתם צריכים מאוד להיזהר בקריאה של התוצאות האבסולוטית האלה.
למה? כי בעצם זה אומר שהבעיה שלכם היא בעיה כזאת ש 90 אחוז אתם כבר משיגים מלדעת את המוח.
סופי can't label ואם אתם מצרפים את זה לזה שרק 100 מילים נגיד הכי נפוצות בשפה, אין כבר מכסות.
איזה מסה משמעותית? כן, מה האינסטנט בכלל של מילים כלומר מילה ונגיד תכסה.
לא יודע מה אחוז אוקיי והמילה Even יכסו עוד חצי אחוז בסדר והמילה Is וכן הלאה ייכנסו עוד אחוז כן וכן הלאה.
אז ואם אתם אז אתם אומרים טוב, אם אני יודע כנראה שאני אדע מה מוסרי קאונט לייבל שלהם נכון?
כי להם בטח יהיה לי מספיק דוגמאות. אוקיי, אז אני אקבל.
ואז אתם אומרים טוב, אז אם הם נותנים לי כבר שמונים אחוז מהאינטרסים אז שמונים אחוז מהאינטרסים אני מקבל כמעט בחינם.
אוקיי, כמעט בלי לטייל, וזה בעצם אומר שכל הרשת מצד אחד זה אומר ש.
אוקיי, יופי, כאילו קיבלתי כבר אחוז דיוק לא רע עם מעט מאוד התעסקות, אבל הצד השני של זה זה שאולי,
אבל לוואצה שלי קצת מטעה, כי בעצם אני ככל הנראה לא רוצה לעשות part speech taking.
בשביל לדעת מה התג הסביר ביותר עבור המילה זה או או או אין או איז נכון.
ככל הנראה הדוגמאות שבגלל מראש רציתי part speech זה כדי שהוא יעשה את יועציה למילים היותר מאתגרות נכון,
או אלה שהן נדירות יחסית, או אלה שמופיעות בכמה סנטים דומיננטיים שאני רוצה להבחין ביניהם.
כלומר בעצם המשחק, למרות שזה נראה כמו מאה אחוז ואז מה זה שני אחוז?
אפשר אולי לטעון שבעצם כל המשחק הוא על הפער בין לא יודע מה 80 אחוז או משהו כזה כן לבין 98 אחוז, או אולי אפילו פחות מזה בסדר.
כלומר, מראש הפער הוא כן הוא.
הפער שאפשר לסגור הוא הרבה יותר מצומצם וככה גם צריך לפרש את התוצאות.
אוקיי, אז זה נקודה אחת.
נקודה אחת שחשוב לי שחשוב לי להדגיש שהרבה פעמים כדאי להסתכל.
כן, ובגלל זה אני מאוד ככה. הייתי מציע לכם לקחת בצורה מאוד זהירה כל מיני אמירות שאומרות כן, אנחנו לא יודע.
לפעמים כותרות בעיתון מתח אנחנו מסננים היטב Speech לא יודע מה.
שבעים וחמש אחוז, שמונים אחוז, תשעים אחוז 99 אחוז כן בפני עצמו.
המשפט הזה לא אומר כלום. אוקיי, אתם צריכים לראות מה זה ה training data?
מה זה הטסטר? אתם צריכים לראות אם זה סטינג אאוט אוף דומינו אין דומיין כי מאוד סביר להניח שהיא משתנה כל הזמן.
נכון? ואתם לא באמת מצפים להיות ב setting שומעים דומיין?
כן, אולי גם יש שפות שונות ואז אתם חשוב לראות על מה הם מדברים.
כן, על אנגלית אולי מדברים על שפות יותר נדירות ואז זה יותר מרשים.
זה דבר נוסף שאתם צריכים לבדוק. אתם צריכים לבדוק שעבדת.
הסרט הזה הוא לא Benchmark שכבר עבדו עליו, חרשו אותו המון המון המון פעמים כמו שעשו עם הסטארט אפ האלה,
ולכן סביר להניח שהרבה מהאפקטים שאתם רואים הם בעצם הסיבה שכל המודלים בערך מקבלים אותו דבר או כמעט אותו דבר.
זה בגלל הרבה סיבות של over פייטינג כן לא עובר פייטינג במובן הפשוט של של זה שלקחתם מודל שהוא אקספרסיבי מדי והוא עשה יותר מדי פילטרים עם Data,
אלא במובן הזה שאתם יודעים, עם כל מאמר יוצא מאמר חדש ואף אחד לא מסתכל על הטסט.
Data כולם מריצים רק בטסט data בסוף, אבל בסוף אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה כאילו כל מאמר הסתכל על הטסט data וכולם מריצים עם אותו טסט data בעבודה אלפיים.
כנראה שהתוצאה היא כבר לא כל כך אמינה.
כן, לא משנה כמה מדענים ניסו לשמור על טוהר המידות, אז כל הדברים האלה תקחו בחשבון כשאתם קוראים וספציפית, אני חושב שהדוגמה הזאת היא דוגמה מעניינת.
על כל פנים, לשיא הרף בהחלט.
בהרבה מאוד מקרים אנחנו רואים גם בפרט בסרטים יותר נדירים ועבור שפות פחות דומיננטיות מאנגלית בהחלט רואים שיפורים משמעותיים על פני שיטות אחרות שקדמו לו.
כן, אנחנו לא יכולים למדוד את זה לפחות על עשרת הדיברות.
לפחות המילים העתידיות שלהם חסרות משמעות.
כלומר, אם כן אז באמת לפעמים.
אז דבר ראשון כנראה לבנות קורפוס או בנצ'מרק שיתעלם מהמילה וזה כאילו אתה יודע אתה לא תצליח למצוא טקסט.
כנראה שאין בו כל כך הרבה את המילים האלה. נכון לספור אותן.
בדיוק. אז זה עניין שמצריכות נכון? בדיוק אז מצריכות בהחלט בהחלט.
בהחלט. אפשר למשל לשאול את השאלה כמה טוב אתה מצליח, נגיד לא לשאול תוכן אלא לשאול על Types.
כלומר, נגיד למשל כמה מילים שונות אתה מצליח לסדוק על האינסטינקטים שלהם לפחות ב 90 אחוז.
נגיד אני אומר נכון ויש גם מדרג. אז נכון, אתה צודק, אבל מה שצריך לקחת בחשבון וזה אולי אני אגיד אנחנו נדבר בהמשך הקורס.
על מה קורה היום באמת, אבל יש הרבה יותר כסף שמושקע באבולוציה של כלי NLP, כי הם הפכו להיות משהו הרבה מסחרית,
הרבה יותר חשוב, ומה שרואים פעם אחר פעם אחר פעם זה מה שנקרא benchmark situation.
כן, אנחנו רואים שמגיעים לתוצאות פנטסטיות, כאילו על כל מיני Benchmark.
הם אפילו בנצ'מרק מאוד מאתגרים באמת, מאוד מאתגרים. זאת אומרת, אני לא טוען שיש כאן איזה כן, איזה טריק או משהו כזה באמת.
הם מאוד מאתגרים ובאמת מודלים מצליחים מהם זה.
אבל צריך לקחת בחשבון שבגלל שכיום נגיד ממודל שפה אתה כבר לא מצפה ממנו שיעשה משהו מסוים, כן או לא יודע, מ agent כן לא יודע לקלוט קוד.
אתה לא מצפה שהוא יצליח בניידת. מי שהרבה בתצפית שלנו אפילו במשימה, הרבה יותר קשה כמו לענות על שאלות טריוויה.
נגיד או משהו כזה, אתה מצפה ממנו לאוסף שאפילו אף אחד בדיוק לא יודע להגדיר מה הגבולות שלו?
כן. ומרגע שאתה בעצם יודע מה הבעיה בכלל, אז אתה כבר בעצם מסתבר שהדרך היא לא מאוד ארוכה בדרך כלל כן עם כמה יוצאי דופן חשובים כדי להצליח עליו.
אפילו אם לא באמת פתרת את האנדרנלין Problem הכללי.
כן, זאת אומרת, אנחנו רואים עוד פעם ועוד פעם תלונות מוצדקות מצד התעשייה שאומרות אבל אתם הראיתם לי שבעצם הדבר הזה הוא טוב.
כלומר בן אדם לא יודע למכור טלוויזיות בשיחת טלפון או בצ'אט או משהו כזה.
כן, אבל שמפעילים את זה אז הם רואים שהוא פחות.
אז מה קורה? כן, זה באמת שאלה סבוכה מאוד.
שאלות נוספות. אוקיי, אחלה.
אז עכשיו אנחנו נתחיל. בעצם אנחנו נעבור לפרק חדש שנקרא א רננים.
כן, ריקון תמר הנץ שלנו.
כן, שעכשיו גם הסיפור בנייד.
רוצים משהו. על כן. למה לא?
אז עוד לא למדנו. אנחנו עוד מעט נלמד על איך עובדים נגיד.
נגיד למשל מודלים כמו נגיד Transformer Base Language Models שעל המטוס הסקריפטים וכאלה.
אבל בעצם, בגדול, מה שאנחנו נראה בהמשך הקורס זה שהגישה הזאת של שפת צוות Production capture פרודקשן.
זה בדיוק הרעיון שאת רוצה לבצע פרט דיקציה למבנה, כלומר לכמה הסטנדרטים שונים בדרך שתהיה תלות בין האפליקציות השונות, בין אם זה לחזות עץ על ידי.
את יודעת לחזות עץ, אבל מטבע הדברים את לא רוצה לחשוב על העץ הזה, פשוט כי כל עץ הוא קטגוריה נפרדת.
איך שהוא רוצה לחזות את כל הצעות הקודקודים שלו ביחד, או בין אם זה לחזות שרשרת, אז בגדול השיטות הרוב,
השיטות העכשוויות מוותרות על לנסות לבצע לבצע structure production ובמקום זה הם הם הם מבצעים בעצם Products להיות בלתי תלויות.
כלומר באמת פריצת דיסק צפויות או בלתי תלויות לגמרי, או מה שקראנו באיזשהו שלב Forward קלאסי.
אפיק יש הרבה קוד, כסף, קשר, כלומר קסקדה שלהם, שבהם נגיד את חוזה חתיכה אחת.
ואז בהינתן הפרס דיסקציה שלך, בשלב הקודם אתה מבצע את הפרויקט הבא, שזה יוצר תלות.
אבל דיברנו על זה שיש עם זה בעיות נכון, כי זה אולי יוצר קסקדה של טעויות עם חשיבות גדולה לאיפה?
כאילו לאפליקציות שביצעת בהתחלה, נכון? אז לא, אז נוטים לעשות כאלה דברים.
ככלל, בגלל שהמודלים מודלי הפרס דיקציה הם פשוט הרבה הרבה יותר חזקים מאשר המודלים שראינו עד עכשיו ואנחנו נדבר על זה.
הם הרבה יותר כבדים. הם מסתמכים על טכניקות יותר חדשות, עם הרבה יותר קומפיוטר, עם הרבה יותר זיכרון והרבה יותר חשמל שמושקע,
אז הם מצליחים במידה רבה להתגבר על זה, מה שהשיטות היותר בסיסיות פשוט זה היה non starter.
הרבה פעמים לא להשתמש בשיא הרף כי כי אז היית עושה לא בלי נייר מודל לוקאלי והיית מקבלת טעות מאוד גדולה.
אז כאילו אם יש לך פיצ'ר Function מאוד מאוד חזק שמבוסס על רשת עם גזי ליין פרמטרים,
אז הפרטי שלך יותר מדויקת ואז יוכן Gateway וזה נחמד להצטייר הרבה פעמים,
אבל מסתבר שיש, ואני חושב שמכירים בזה לפחות חלק מהאנשים שבהרבה מקרים את כן רוצה בכל זאת את הפרטיות production, כי בעצם אין שום דבר שנוגד.
אין, אין שום מתח אמיתי בין structure production לבין השיטות הנורמליות.
הסיבה שעזבו את ה structure production או שהיה לזה עשור קצת חלש,
הייתי אומר בעשור האחרון היא בגלל שמודל הפרס דיקציה השתפרו באופן כזה שהערך המוסף שלהם כבר לא היה נראה גדול.
כן, אבל. אבל זה לא של החליפו אותם באופן מהותי שהם יודעים לחשב.
לבצע תחזית של מבנה גלובלי בצורה שהיא פשוט עדיפה.
הם פשוט ויתרו על זה לטובת שיטות דיקציה הרבה יותר מדויקות, ויורי ספיקות כדי לקרב פתרון Structure בלי באמת לבצע בדיקה גלובלית.
אוקיי. כן, אני אשמח אם תסביר שוב מה הכוונה בשיחה.
אני חושב שזה בערך בהנחה שאלה מקוצרת שנוגעת למשפט.
אוקיי, אבל סביר שזה יהיה אפילו באופיו.
אני ניקח את הדוגמה שלך של לגמור את משפט. כן, אז אתה אומר אני רוצה עכשיו לייצר משפט.
איזה משפט זה לא יודע, נגיד תרגום של משהו או לא יודע סיכום של ווטאבר.
כן. אז אוקיי, אז אתה אומר המשפט הזה יש לי בעצם הרבה מאוד אפשרויות.
למה הוא יכול להיות נכון? הוא יכול להיות משפט באורך באיזשהו אורך, אפילו אם נקבע לו את האורך.
יש הרבה מאוד סדרות אפשריות של מילים שאני עשוי לשקול לייצר ואני רוצה לבחור את ההכי טוב מביניהם.
אוקיי, independent production זה היה משהו כמו לנסות לחזות כל אחת מהמילים בנפרד.
זאת אומרת, נגיד אני קודם חוזה שאני צריך תרגום בן 17 מילים כן ולא 16 או 15 או 20.
ואחרי זה להגיד אוקיי, מה סביר ביותר שהיא המילה הראשונה, מה סביר במילה השנייה וכן הלאה.
מודלים כיום ואנחנו נראה את זה עוד מעט. הם לא עובדים ככה.
הם עובדים בצורה אוטו אגרסיבית. כלומר הם קודם חוזים נגיד את הראשון ואז בהינתן הראשון את השני ואז בהינתן השני והראשון את השלישי וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן. זה בדיוק הנושא שאנחנו מגיעים אליו עכשיו, אבל גם זה לא structure production.
נכון? כי אמרנו שה structure production זה בעצם פרי דיסקציה שעושה כאילו את הכל ביחד.
נכון, אני מנסה למצוא שרשרת לתת score לשרשרת ואז לנסות למצוא מה השרשרת האופטימלית.
כן, זה מין יוריס זיקה כזאת נכון, אבל ממש לא בטוח שתמצא את השרשרת האופטימלית ככה.
למעשה, די בטוח שלא. כי זה מין צורה Credit כזאת לעשות את זה.
ואז השאלה מה אתה מפסיד? כן, אם מראש הפרי ויקטור שלך היה פנטסטי, אז אולי אין לך טעם למדל את המבנה.
נכון, אתה לא מרוויח מזה כמעט כלום, כי אתה יכול להגיד לו מה המילה הטובה ביותר עבור המילה השלישית בתרגום שלי, ואחרי זה לשאול אותו אפילו לא בסדר.
רציף באיזשהו סדר. מה זה משנה? הוא יודע. תשאל אותו קודם על השלישית.
אחרי זה אם בא לך לשאול אותו על השמינית, 9 על השמינית אחרי זה שישית.
ואם אידיאלי נכון, אם יש איזשהו מודל אידיאלי אתה מקבל בדיוק את אותו דבר.
לא משנה באיזה סדר תחזיר אותם, ננתח. זה כל פעם יחידים או זוגות או את הכל ביחד.
תמיד תקבל בדיוק אותו דבר כי הוא מושלם. אתה מושלם!
אין, אבל אם אתה קרוב למושלם אז כנראה זה גם לא כל כך נורא.
אם תחווה את זה ככה או ככה או ככה. ואם אתה יותר רחוק ממושלם אז זה מתחיל קצת להכאיב לך.
אוקיי, אז Soccer production זה לחזות ביחד, לבצע איזשהו production של כמה דברים ביחד.
נגיד במקרה של צורות משפט, של חתיכות שלמות, של המשפט ביחד, אולי אפילו של כל המשפט ביחד.
אז לא היית מודע למה ראינו? בהחלט פשוט לא בצינורות משפט.
כן ראינו את זה עבור ספיץ. הנה נכון אמרנו ויתר בי.
מה ויטרוביוס הוא עושה structure difference. נכון הוא מצא אתה בעצם יש לך את המודל נגיד card איפה הוא מגדיר score?
עבור כל היפותזה אפשרית יש מקסימום גלובלי.
נכון, יש אופטימלי, גלובלי ואביתר מבצע אותו בצורה מדויקת.
לא מקורבת. נכון, הוא ממש מפרק את הבעיה לחתיכות, פותר אותם בשלבים ומקבל בסוף את הפתרון האופטימלי.
כן, אז במובן הזה הוא באמת מבצע Structure body.
כשהוא מוצא הוא חוזה את כל השרשרת ביחד.
הוא לא אומר אה, אוקיי, נראה לי קודם שהראשון זה זה a ואם הראשון זה A אז כנראה השני זה b ואם השני זה b אז כנראה השלישי זה c וכן הלאה.
והדוגמאות הקודמות שהתבססו על פה לא נחשבות לשפה.
אז בגדול, בדרך כלל כשמדברים על software production אז מדברים על בעיית קלסי פיקציה.
כן, אז בהחלט כל המודלים, כל המודלים, פרסי פיקציה שדיברנו עליהם בהקשר של HTML MMC.
כן, זה סוג של Structure, זה סיקוונס structure.
כן, זה סוג מסוים של Structure שהוא מבנה ליינר, כי אנחנו ניתקל גם בסוגים אחרים של structure בהמשך נגיד מבנה של עץ.
אוקיי. בארני, כפי שאנחנו עוד מעט נראה אולי בשיעור הבא, כבר אין לנו המון זמן.
זה לא יהיה Start ספרדית. שם זה יהיה משהו אחר.
ואז אנחנו ננסה קצת לפצות על זה שאנחנו לא עושים structure production על ידי כל מיני פסיקות שאומנם לא ישיגו פתרון מדוייק,
אבל לפעמים זה גודל בסדר, אבל עוד לא ראינו את זה.
אז בסדר. עוד חזון למועד.
טוב, אז בואו קצת נתחיל לדבר על הרמן. ברור לי שאת עיקר כן עיקר החומר יעבור בשיעור הבא, אבל קצת נכיר את המושגים.
דבר ראשון, מכיוון שכמעט כולם כאן לקחו אי מייל.
ואני אז רציתי לשאול אתכם אתם לקחתם את זה כבר בשנה שמלמדים ארמנים בשנים שכבר
מלמדים ארמנים באמת מישהי או מישהו מכאן לא למדו על הרמן באימייל או במסגרת אחרת.
אוקיי, אבל אני יודע שזה משהו יחסית מוגבל. נכון, הלימוד שם או שלא זוכרים את זה אפילו תפוח אחד.
מה ההמצאה הבאה? אוקיי, בסדר, אז אנחנו דיברתם על ההקשר של Language.
מודלינג, אמר. הנני מניח שלא נכון לפרסם כמה זה יותר טוב.
אוקיי, בסדר, אז כמו שבסין הם הזכירו לנו כאילו משהו נוח כן או שעשינו על זה?
כן לא ברור. גם אנחנו לא נעשה על זה קורס, אבל זה יהיה פרק וזה פרק די חשוב.
אז ככה בסדר אז. אבל בכל מקרה אני בכלל עובר.
אני כן, אני כן נגדיר דברים מהתחלה, אבל מצד שני אני כן מניח שנתקלתם בזה קודם מבחינת הפירוט של ההסברים.
אבל תשאלו אם משהו לא פה אז בסדר. אז בעצם אנחנו שוב ושוב.
עד עכשיו נתקלנו בבעיה של גודל הקונטקסט.
נכון, נתקלנו בה גם בבעיה של Language מודלים, אמר קובלאי Image Models שאמרנו בסדר,
אנחנו מצד אחד רוצים לקחת קונטקסט שהוא מספיק ארוך כדי לתפוס כל מיני תלויות.
מצד שני הוא יותר מדי ארוך.
הספר City, הסיבוך שזה יהרוג אותנו אם נתקלנו בזה ב Home ובשיא הרף, ובהם אמ ובכל הגישות האלה, מה שבעצם אמרנו זה מה שיבוא לעזרתנו.
זה בעצם הנחת המרחב. קוביות כן, אמרנו בסדר. הקונטקסט ליינס הוא אם אני איכשהו חוסם אותו ומניח שרוב אז אינטרקציה מעניינת קורית בצורה לוקאלית,
אז יש לי דרך להתמודד עם זה, אז יש לי דרך להתמודד עם זה.
יחד עם זאת, ברור שיש מקרים שבהם אנחנו צריכים קונטקסט שהוא לא בגודל של אחד, שניים או שלוש או ארבע,
שזה בערך המקסימום שמשתמשים בהם בשרשראות מרקוב, פשוט כי יותר מזה כבר מספר תגיות כן ומספר רצפים.
מספר פרמטרים נעצום ונגיד למשל בסנטימנט analysis.
נכון, דיברנו על זה שהיא התלויות בהרבה מקרים.
הן יכולות להיות די ארוכות. נכון, דיברנו על Wanted Expect 9 Hans, למשל.
נכון שבו אני מציג דווקא משהו בצורה חיובית, ואז אני אומר, אבל בסיכומו של דבר מדובר בסרט זבל.
אל תראו אותו. שיעמום נורא נכון, כל מיני דברים כאלה.
בקיצור יש תלויות די די רחוקות בטקסט וצריך לעשות איתם משהו.
דיברנו קצת על יורי שתיקות כאלה. נכון, מניקוי כן, דרך היא כזה של אוקיי, נגיד Negative.
אני רוצה לקחת בחשבון את זה שיש שלילה בתחילת המשפט או כמה תוכנם קודם בסדר.
אם זה לא נכנס לי בתוך המודל המקומי שלי אז לא נורא.
אני פשוט אחליף עם איזושהי מיסטיקה פשוטה כזאת את כל המילים שבאות אחרי Not ונגיד
לפני הפסיק בתוכן שמסמן שזה like is not וזה this is not ומובאים not וכן הלאה.
אבל גם דיברנו על המגבלות של השיטות הפרימיטיביות האלה ועל זה שהרבה פעמים הם לא מצליחות.
תכלס, היינו רוצים יותר. היינו רוצים להחזיק יותר קונטקסט או להחזיק קונטקסט בצורה יותר מתוחכמת.
כן, אז כן, אלה זה פשוט חזרה על הדוגמאות שראינו שראינו בשיעור על סנטימנט.
כן וכן. וזו דוגמה אחת. אבל תכלס, גם בהקשר אפילו בהקשרים, לא של סנטימנט על אלה משימות מאוד פשוטות, כן, כמו התאמה של כן, התאמה של מספר.
אמה של מספר כי אין כבר בדואים בין הנושא של המשפט.
הגרעין של הנושא של המשפט הוא בין מילת הפועל.
גם שם התלויות יכולות להיות בהחלט מעבר לשלוש ארבע, או כן זה בערך הגודל המקסימלי של קונטקסט שלוקחים במודלים הרקובים.
נגיד אם The Brown Cat Desire מהאי Sleep Yesterday, נכון,
עוד Brown Cats Distance Step הספרדי בשניהם הצילו אותי במילה cat עוקץ שהם רחוקים כמה וכמה מילים אחורה, ואפשר כמובן להעריך את המרחק הזה בקלות.
בקיצור, קונטקסט זה עניין חשוב. ברור ששלוש ארבע זה נותן משהו, אבל לא נותן מספיק.
כן, זה דוגמה לסנטימנט. אז שוב אותו ריי אאוט.
כן, יונת סי אס מובי ישנה את עצמו והיא תכלס גרמים והיו נגרמים די דומים.
אבל ברור שהכוונה שונה. אמ.
ובעצם דרך אחת לחשוב על עלה רננים זה בעצם כמין מודל שהוא גם מודל דומה למלכה וי, או אפילו סוג של מודל מר קובי, אבל שיש בו כן איזשהו טוויסט, כן.
אז מהו אותו הטוויסט שאני מדבר עליו? אז אם אתם זוכרים כן, מודלי מרקוב אפשר בעצם להציג אותם.
אפשר לייצג אותם כמין אוטומט כזה? כן, על פני הלייבלים האפשריים על פני הלייבלים העיקריים.
במקרה הזה זה לייבלים של Part of Speech Tracks, אבל לא משנה אם זה הנחות מילים, אם זה language,
מודלינג וכן הלאה יחד עם הסתברויות מעבר כן, ובעצם אם אני המצב שלי מקודד את הקונטקסט שהראיתי.
כן, אם זה היה part speech האחרון זה by גרא מודל או אולי שני אחרונים או שלושת האחרונים, או מה שזה לא יהיה שנכנס לי בקונטקסט Link.
אבל בעצם אני תכלס הייתי יכול לקחת את אותו Framework כן של מרקוב.
מודל שעובר בין מצבים ולהגיד במקום שיהיה לי איזשהם מעברים דטרמיניסטי כאלה.
כן, זאת אומרת פונקציית מעברים דטרמיניסטית שאומרת וזה מניסיון במובן שאני אומר שאם אני עכשיו ראיתי פרופר none אז זה אומר ש.
ועכשיו נתקלתי ב terminal אז זה אומר שאני עכשיו עובר למצב בטרמינל ושוכח לגמרי שקודם הייתי בפרופיל נכון?
כי אני בביתר אז זה כל מה שאני זוכר, או אם הייתי בטרייה גרם אז הייתי אומר צר לזכור את שני האחרונים,
אבל ברגע שאני עובר לאחד חדש, ברור שאני חייב לשכוח את מה שקרה שתיים אחורה כדי לפנות מקום לזה שראיתי עכשיו, נכון?
אז יש איזשהי דרך מאוד מסויימת לנהל את הזיכרון.
כן, כל פעם אני שומר רק את מה שקרה ממש בסוף.
בקייס לא תם בכי סרטים האחרונים שזה גודל הקונטקסט שהגדרתי.
במקום זה אני יכול להגדיר ששת המצבים שלי יהיה וקטור.
כן, בעצם יהיה לי עכשיו איזשהו. אם בדיוק כן יצא לכם להיתקל במילה עם בדיוק ובאמת מדברים משתמשים זה כן, זה פשוט.
זה מין מילה כללית כזאת שבגדול מדברת על זה שאנחנו מייצגים משהו במרחב שהוא לרוב במקור לא מרחב וקטורי, אבל אנחנו מייצגים אותו.
וקטור כן מייצגים אותו באיזה שהוא מרחב אוקלידי, באיזשהו מרחב מממד סופי נתון.
אז הנה, אז בואו אולי נייצג את הקונטקסט.
לא פשוט כשרשרת כקהילה של מצבים של התגים האחרונים שביקרנו בהם, אלא כאיזשהו וקטור.
ואנחנו נחשוב על הווקטור הזה כמייצג את כל ההיסטוריה של מה שקרה עד עכשיו ויהיה לנו איזה שהיא פונקציה נלמדת.
אוקיי, שהיא בעצם תהיה פונקציית המעברים. היא תסביר לנו איך לעדכן את הווקטור הזה, את וקטור הקונטקסט בהינתן אובזרבר חדשים.
כן, בהינתן Data חדש שאנחנו נחשפים אליו ואז בכל שלב אומנם לא יהיה לי את כל ההיסטוריה בסדר,
כי לזכור את כל ההיסטוריה בדיוק מאותן בעיות של spark city וכאלה זה כנראה לא רעיון טוב.
זה לא כל כך מאפשר לנו הכללה מוגבלת.
כן, אבל הופך אותנו. אולי זה יותר מדי אקספרסיבי, זה עשוי לגרום לאובר, אבל במקום הזה נגיד בסדר, אתם לא.
אני לא ממש זוכר את כל ההיסטוריה עבר בייטים. כן, מילה, מילה.
אבל נזכור וקטור שבאיזשהו מובן דוחס את ההיסטוריה.
כן, כך שמה שהכי רלוונטי לי להמשך הפריט אקציות הוא זה שימשיך להיות מקודד.
כן, אז מה האינטואיציה? אז האינטואיציה? למשל, בואו נזכר כאן כן, בעצם כאן בדברים, כעדות היסטורית מהאיסלאם פייסטה.
די ISO כן, תכלס, כל מה שהיינו צריכים לזכור ממה.
קרה קודם. זה משחקים של שקט, שעכשיו אם אתה עומד להיתקל בבור שהוא שהנושא שלו זה מה שקרה קודם, תזכור שהגרעין של הנושא הזה זה כץ.
כן, שהוא זה או לא משנה, או שהגרעין של הנושא הזה הוא ביחיד.
כן שהביטוי הזה שהנושא הוא ביחיד זה כל מה שצריך לזכור וכל עוד זה לא משתנה,
כל עוד אני רואה עוד ועוד מילים אבל הן מילים טובות ומעניינות, רק שהן לא משפיעות.
על השאלה אם הוא ביחיד או ברבים זה לא מעניין אותי לצורך הפרטי הזאת.
אוקיי, אולי לצורך פרטי קצת אחרות? כן, אבל הרעיון הוא שגם אם זה פרדי קצוות די מתוחכמות, נגיד סנטימנט Analysis.
לזכור את השלילה זה גם כל כל עוד אני בסקופ של השלילה, כדאי לזכור שאני בשלילה.
כשאני כבר לא בסקופ של השלילה אני יכול למחוק את הדבר הזה.
אוקיי, אז אם היה לי מין מכונה פלאית כזאת שיודעת לנהל לי את הזיכרון, כן, זאת אומרת, היא מן אדפטיבית.
כן, היא למדה מאתרים, איגדה איתה לא רק באיזה קונטקסט לבצע איזה פרי דיסקציה.
כן, כלומר את הקישור הזה בין Context לבין like ללייבל, אלא היא למדה מה לזכור ומה לשכוח.
או במילים אחרות איך לעדכן את הזיכרון בצורה אפקטיבית, כך שיהיה לי שם את עיקר המידע שאני צריך כדי לבצע את הפרידה קצת בהמשך.
אז יופי, אז אני כבר לא צריך שרשראות מרקוב מסדר זה.
ליון שאני, שזה לא פרקטי בכלל ואני לא אצליח. אני צריך איזשהו וקטור צנוע ששומר את המעט שמחזיק את המרובה.
נכון, זה זה בערך הרעיון. איך אני אצליח למצוא כזה?
בגדול, התשובה היא כפי שאתם יכולים להניח בשלב הזה, אחרי שלקחתם את האימייל, זה שאני לא באמת אצליח למצוא את הפונקציה הפלאית הזאת.
אבל בשאיפה, אם אתם מאמינים לדי הרבה תוצאות אמפיריות באמצעותה רננים והצלחה יחסית,
אפשר לקבל איזשהו קירוב לא רע לאותה פונקציה פלאית משהו סביר שמצליח לזכור את העיקר
ולהתעלם מהתפריט בהרבה מאוד הקשרים באמצעות טכנולוגיה שנקראת REM ועל זה בשבוע הבא.
אז להתראות. נתראה. קופת את המדינה.
אולי זאת התמורה. אפשר לעשות את זה פחות או יותר בי.
אתה רוצה לסחור על כל? אתה מדבר על האלפא בתור ביקורות?
אז מה זה לסחוב על הקהל? לסחוב על הכל? לא, זה לא ייתכן כי תסתכל מה אתה בעצם עושה לכל קודקוד.
אתה מחזיק איזשהו אלפא באיזשהו בטא, נכון?
אז מספר אלפא ומספר אותו כמספר הקודקודים.
כן, זה לא כמות אקספוננציאלית וכל אחד מהם אתה יודע לחשב באמצעות השכבה הקודמת.
בזמן לינארי כן, אני יכול לא יחשב, אבל למה לא כן?
ככה אתה צריך לחשב? כן. אז בעצם מה זה אומר? זה אומר שהכל נכון וכל מה שאתה צריך זה לסכום על הקודקודים שהם מספרים.
כן. אז בעצם אתה חוסך.
אתה חוסך הרבה חישוב כי כי עבור איזשהו מסלול שהגיע עד לכאן אתה בעצם לא צריך.
נגיד, היית רוצה לסחוב על פני כל המסלולים? אז היית על הרישא הזאת?
סוכם גם במסלול הזה וגם במסלול הזה וגם במסלול הזה.
כן, היית עושה את המכפלה הזאת של הרישא? המון המון פעמים כאן אתה לא עושה אותה המון פעמים.
נכון, אתה בעצם עושה אותה פעם אחת וכל פעם מעריך אותה.
כי כאילו אני לוקח את הדבר הזה לא הייתה הכי טובה שם.
זה לא. מקסימום על הסכום. אתה לוקח את הסכום, אתה לוקח את הסכום של כל מה שמגיע עד כאן ועכשיו.
אתה אומר הסכום של כל מה שמגיע עד כאן. זה סכום של מה שמגיע עד כאן כפולה מעבר לסכום של מה שמגיע עד כאן, כולל מעבר לסכום שמה שזה ואתה מחבר את כולם.
אתה חושב על זה? זה בעצם מאוד דומה לביתר ולפני.
זה מאוד דומה לביתר ברק רק עם סכום במקום מקסימום בעצם.
לצערנו עדיין לא מצליח להבין איך זה שאנחנו, אה. אז תנסה פשוט לקחת דוגמה, לשרטט את זה.
וכן, תראה שאתה עושה את זה כבר בשקופית האחרונה שהצגתי לך את הכי מתקדמת.
שאלת שאלות. אה של מושג איך. תוכל להספיק.
אופס. כן, מה זה כאן? פיינליסטית אותה מקום.
שכחתי את ראשי התיבות. כן כן, אבל בסדר.
גם אם אני לא זוכר את זה זה זה יותר מוטיבציה.
למה אתה אומר אותו? אתם עומדים על אותו סכום?
יש החזר? יש אוטומטים לחישוב יותר נכון, אבל זה לא כולם לקחו.
בטח שכבר בשלב הזה אני שנה רביעית. אני לא יודע מה קורה עם האחרים.
אני גם מהנדס הספציפי, גם למדתי בעיבוד אותות של מערכות ביום.
טוב, אז. מה שאהבתי בתוכנית.
למרות.